the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
warmer weather has arrived in the
Central West End but there's a chill in
the playing Hall at the Cairns Cup in
Saint Louis
these ladies are friends before the
rounds but kind looks turned to frigid
glares over the board a blunder by Nana
zagnitzi opened the door to an avalanche
of trouble leading to a meltdown against
Irina Crush who calmly took the win and
jumped into Cove first of the event
two players are tied at the top with a
pack of wolves in hot Pursuits can they
run away with their lead or will they
slip up and let it go day four of
invigorating chess
coming up next
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to round
four of the Karen's cup here in San Luis
I'm currently at the Q Boutique at the
World Chess Hall of Fame if you're in
San Luis you should definitely check it
out but for now let's go to the studio
and get the game started
welcome to San Luis the home of Chess in
America and the third edition of the
Karens cup one of the richest women's
tournaments in chess we come to your
life from the San Luis chess club
foreign
good morning and welcome everyone thank
you for joining us I'm International
Master Nazi Pai kids and I'm here with
my brilliant co-host Justin
you know I'm a sucker for flattery be
careful with that brilliant stuff
wonderful wonderful to call all the
action the fighting games have been
tremendous has been great enjoying
myself so thank you thank you hello
everyone and Welcome to our show thank
you very much for sharing your day with
us if you like Fighting Chess you came
to the right place we have some
surprises and the top of the standing is
two Americans are sharing the podium do
the honors Nasi and tell us who is in
the lead right let's take a look after
three rounds we have two call leaders
Alexandra castino can Irina crush with
two and a half points out of three very
impressive the clear third another
American Ana zatoski with two points out
of three a nice surprise for sure and
with 50 we have four players harika
Journal
there with no points Ben tell us about
the format we have a 10 player round
robin tournament no trophers allowed and
they have classical time control 90
minutes for first 40 moves 30 minutes
rest of the game and 30 second increment
from move one our schedule in the
tournament all right the players will
play nine rounds total today they're
playing round four and on Thursday June
8th they will have a rest day kind of
looking forward to that in that Sprint
to the finish with four rounds to go and
we're so happy to have in studio Almera
to call all the action with the chess
engines and we do have that surprise at
the top how did the how did the ladies
get there hello yes sir hello Nazi first
of all so happy to be here wanted to
paraphrase Judy Garland so meet me in
Saint Louis Louis but meet me at the
chess clubs
let's have a look uh who is leading the
tournament after the first three rounds
so alone on the third place is Anna
zatonskik the American Champions scored
two points out of three in the first
round she Drew Nana jagnitzel one of the
top players in the world then she beat
Bella Hotel Nashville and yesterday she
Drew Elizabeth pets tied for first is
another American champion Irina crash
she scored two and a half points out of
three she started with an incredible win
against Jean Sai abdumelik with black
then she Drew with black once again
against hampi konera with defending
champion and yesterday she defeated Nana
jagnitzel
on the first position
as well is Alexander questinook former
world champion she beat Hamby Corner in
the first round please have a look at
this game incredible combination at the
end in the second round she beat Harry
cardrona Valley and yesterday she Drew
with black against gunai mamajada so she
scored also two and a half points out of
three and let's have a look at the
ratings of this event American players
were the lowest seed of this event when
they were considered probably as easy
targets at the beginning of this event
but not anymore yes sir what do you
think not so easy at all not when
they're on top of the leaderboard as
we've seen and I see yeah do the honors
tell our viewers what they can expect
for this round four pairings please
let's take a look in round four hampi
conero is playing nanotechnitzel
playing one of the leaders of the
tournament Irina Crush absolutely
Elizabeth pets against John Sayer Abdul
Malik and probably our key matchup
karstenyuk against satonski absolutely a
player in first versus player in third
you bet and hurricane
a Fighting Chess throughout what are the
ladies fighting for they're fighting for
a lot of money there's a total of
hundred and eighty thousand dollars in
prizes the first place winner is going
to win 45 000 second place thirty five
thousand third twenty five thousand very
nice indeed all the way down to the
tenth and final position of six thousand
dollars as we were seeing that the World
Chess Hall of Fame the players are
getting ready taking their seats and I I
noticed uh
Alexandra as she was sitting down she
does the first thing that I always like
to do I always like to adjust my pieces
on the back rank make sure that they're
all perfectly centered and then I do the
pawns do you do the same thing
yes yes I do I just never noticed but I
definitely do exactly how you described
it exactly but now here's the key
question
do you do it for your opponent as well
me either but I have had opponents who
like to even adjust my business and it's
like no no no right Elmira no no no what
you want to do with your visas is fine
but leave mine alone did you ever
experience that opponent suggesting your
pieces
um well I don't recollect but they had
the one opponent who was clean in the
board cleaning the board
like with sanitizer yeah but way before
the pandemic he just liked the you know
the squares to me shiny the shiny and
I'm I'm noticing that for many of the
players they have their Knights facing
towards one another
and I noticed that Alexandra had her
Knights facing to the opponents uh so
there's the knights facing one another
and I think in Alexandra's case facing
her opponent I like my Knights facing my
opponent
forwards how about yourself for the
nights
I think they're always facing each other
sideways Almera uh facing my opponent
yes
I'm sorry you were so close on this one
now so yeah you got to give you this is
an Art of War so you have to face your
opponents
chess is a game of war and ladies I
really thought about it this morning in
the shower what are we going to name our
chess engine and it came to me
Oracle
we how do you feel about the Oracle we
can refer to the Oracle because in the
Greek mythology oftentimes the Oracle
spoke with a feminine voice I like it
very much so not the Delphi historical
but it will be Saint Louis Oracle
precisely not the Oracle Adelphi the
Oracle of St Louis you're okay with
orange
tell us what you think and also by the
way big shout out we love being
challenged by the social media and you
can join our conversation whenever you
like and you can also subscribe to our
social media so please do that uh stay
in touch right our social media managers
provides you with so many behind the
scenes pictures and videos and she likes
to talk to the players right after the
game and you can get those
emotions that you don't necessarily see
otherwise and this is how you can do it
you can send us tweets using Karen's cup
or you can also send us your questions
on YouTube and twitch St Louis chess
club channels exactly I wanted to ask
you both about Nana yesterday when she
made that blunder in the ending that
allowed Arena to tie for First with
Alexandra get into her mindset because
she blundered with the black pieces and
now she's facing the defending champion
and the highest rated player in the
field no mercies for a bad game
yes like I said yesterday you might have
a bad day or just a bad move like she
did yesterday and then the next day
instead of getting some rest or an easy
game easy opponent you might face
someone even stronger and more
challenging precisely uh how do you deal
with that on there
oh well yesterday you were talking about
the Greek mythology and I was thinking
how much do you need to do to win such
tournaments so the first day you need to
kill the Minotaur you know the second
day you need to do something
extraordinary once again and Nazi is
right
you don't have an easy day in those
tournaments
that's the problem with super
tournaments right
the is it seven challenges nine
challenges of Hercules twelve challenges
my goodness in our case it's nine nine
rounds uh as the play is underway Bella
roller coaster ride for her for sure she
started with two losses one we ascribed
to jet lag as she blundered her
preparation but yesterday she played a
really nice game and especially to close
it out I mean she found all of those
absolutely crucial moves at a crucial
moment even when she didn't have that
much time around the clock as well right
her in-game technique was absolutely
perfect with just one minute on the
clock yeah and very very very impressive
play am I looking at a London feels that
way Bishop F4 yet
yeah we have D4 D5 Bishop F4 becoming
more and more popular the the London
variation I've
um well I mean it's
who can I really can a man absolutely
Hikaru for sure and then I guess Magnus
even started adopting uh this age-old
bishop F4 just developing the bishop
bringing it out early
playing E2 E3
shortly thereafter uh I think Loren also
likes it maybe not with this move order
but London in general right and it's
been and and infused with the modern
engines uh including ideas of Knight C3
I think I I think I'll give yobova some
credit as well because he he's he he's
been throwing it out there for a number
of years E2 E3 on the board and there is
a line specific line in the London that
is referred to as jababa variation right
and that's with Castle in queenside
where's that see I'm I'm not you're not
a London system no I'm not a player
yourself so the idea is very simple I
mean you're looking
uh to essentially take advantage of the
fact that your opponent needs to counter
in the center with the move C7 C5 your
Bishop on F4 your Pawn on D4 really is
preventing the move E5 so you're almost
for sure thinking yeah that's what
you've got to do you've got to play C7
C5 with your Bishop already lurking on
this diagonal this idea is that
sometimes you're going to play Knight to
C3 Knight to B5 and other times you're
thinking I can capture this Pawn on C5
Knight D2 already on the board as the
players are kind of going fairly quickly
I want to say Knight C6 Knight F3 pretty
sure they both been
prepared and ready for this exactly and
um
usually you choose London system to
avoid a lot of theory right and also to
play a familiar positions right exactly
pretty much no matter how black response
you can have a similar setup from the
white side exactly yeah
almost like a Kali system you know where
your pieces are going to go as uh we'll
keep an eye on this one and let's go to
our other Tournament co-leader game
where are
that's unfortunately well that's that's
interesting I'm not actually getting
moves I had actually put in those moves
of uh Bella and Arena so I'm having a
little awkward I think we're on delay
well that's definitely one way of
putting it uh absolutely uh we are but I
think almira's got some moves so she can
update us please well I can at least
update you on the opening because I know
this idea so I looked the moves on your
board looked up so here after Knight bd2
one of the main ideas is Queen B6
exactly and I'm pretty sure that arena
is thinking right now if she is going to
choose this variation because it's quite
considered to be quite dangerous even
though the computer evaluates it is
well equal or even slightly better for
black but you need to know a precise
sequence of moves here so after Queen B6
usually you play D takes C5 and here a
very strange move after Queen C5 but
it's a very good one A3 and here
actually computer evaluates and a lot of
games have been played that this
position is a much better for white
because you don't know how to develop
your pieces so if you let's say you will
go for G6 then well you can play C4 and
even B4 but this Knight is very strange
what I like about those positions that
they're very difficult to ever lead
why Bella chose this opening is because
arena is a very classical player hair
education her Edition are simply immense
so she is trying to uh well to throw her
off the usual grounds and so after d
takes C5 normally you would take on B2
and there was a recent game played by
Magnus Carlson against England in this
variation so after Queen B2 usually play
Rook B1 then Queen C3 and then very it's
a very important inclusion you play
Bishop B5
don't ask me wise because you need of
course to to pin this night and to fight
for this E5 Square that's one of the
strategical ideas so let me see uh so
after Bishop B5 you can play E6 in order
to finish your development then you
simply Castle
Bishop B7 you can also take on C5 but
let's say Bishop B7 it was the game
between Elyria zafirja and here a lot of
games continued like this E4 so
completely crazy position wow and I'm
pretty sure that Bella is aiming for
such type of plane that's a super sharp
double-edged I thought you were going to
say say Bishop E5 and Away you go uh
well arena is really uh pondering uh
that decision to play the move uh Queen
B6 or not if she doesn't uh do you think
if you're not prepared for this exact
line maybe you should avoid sharp move
like Queen B6 and instead just play E6
and develop pieces right yes that's what
I was going to say that very standard is
and again from the very recent Stavanger
event that's going on E7 E6 is a very
typical play from Black's perspective
you kind of keep the bishop back for a
moment and let's just say I'll play a
move like C3 you play Bishop D to D6 and
after for example Bishop G3 maintaining
the tension castles Bishop D3 this is
really uh safe kind of standard stuff
that you don't have to
go into those double-edged lines if
you're black and you're thinking okay I
just want an easy game but at the same
time there's a lot of theory in this
position true thousands of games yeah
and I've been uh I've had this position
from the black side at least dozen of
times really yes okay so you you've been
facing the London uh a lot yeah but
always successfully so that's why I
don't like it for a while well okay well
that's a good thing I mean obviously our
viewers would be very interested uh you
you've played this position for black
I'm assuming you play B6 yes yeah B7 B6
uh castles Bishop B7 as you say lots and
lots of theory going on Intel break it
down for us why do you like black let's
say
right so
if white doesn't take control of the E5
Square early then there were games where
I've managed to play Queen C7 and E5 or
queen E7 and E5 right I love those
positions when black gets to take
control of the center exactly it feels
like I'm playing with the from the white
side like I just gotta you got the
initiative right exactly and when white
does play I'll say 95 and goes F4 and
goes all in right on the king side then
I get a counter play on The Queen side I
start
Pawn marches with a a6b5 depends exact
move or it depends on what white is
doing but you go Queen side yes and I
enjoyed I I'm a defendant player I think
so I like defending on the king side no
you're not a defendant you're a counter
attacker yes you don't seize the
defenses
but you counter attack yeah and I know
what you're saying and for me by the way
I love I love these uh fights uh
strategical fights you white is battling
for the center you're you're you're
battling for some uh Queen side
developments and I believe our games are
back Almera and what openings uh check
our leaders game right now against Anna
satonski French defense and it's been
plain French I think for many many years
exactly well I there was again the
Stavanger tournament uh forgive me for
referring to that it's so such a fresh
event that's going on uh Fabiano is
doing great I mean he once on the
recently on the live ratings he went
funny in that tournament Americans are
doing great as well
were in the first and second place
exactly and Fabi had not defeated Magnus
Carlson in a classical game in eight
years wow eight years and in round one
they matched up in a French defense and
Fabi destroyed destroyed Magnus it was a
it was a brilliant brilliant effort no
he had played uh the classical Knight C3
and not the winner War but actually
Knight F6 E5 Knight back F4 that was
again the game of Fabiano and Magnus
that was just played E4 E5 the advanced
French defense you know it's strange
today people are playing the advanced
French defense it's like
it's come back in fashion
exactly and I I if you only played the
advanced French against me I'd be
playing French all the time because I
have played numerous games
where
I got you to close the center and I want
to control the F5 Square so I like my
knight not on the D7 Square I like the
night on the G8 Square so I could go H5
at night I think it was a Carol kind of
player I always wondered why would black
choose to play this one you can get this
exact position without the bad Bishop on
C8 exactly what could be sweeter putting
your Bishop on F5 in a in an advanced uh
French defense okay E5 C5 C3 Knight C6
Knight F3 talk about playing hundreds of
thousands of games from this position
away you go Queen B6 Mainline staff
Knight A3 a little bit off the Beaten
Track for sure Amira uh Knight A3 not an
everyday move for this position
very interesting
thing is Alexandra's behalf and I wanted
to explain to you a few ideas in this
opening so Knight S3 one of the key
elements to consider in this position is
the pound on D4 uh black is ferociously
attacking the bone and white is always
always defending the the keychain so why
Knight S3 there are a few moves here but
C takes D4 is the main line so you would
take on Z4 then black normally gives
this check
so Bishop D2 and here you have a few
options I think that Anna is probably
looking for an ig7 so how would you
consider after this then this knight
from A3 simply goes to situ and once
again we have this Motif that white will
sacrifice the pound on B2
so Bishop D2 Queen D2 and black can
actually take the pound on B2 why are
they saying okay come down Bishop G3 I'm
sacrificing this Pawn in order to have
once again a long-term initiative if
you're going to Castle kingside and my
Bishop is already looking on H7 there
were a few games in this line and this
position is considered the computer
doesn't like it because uh black is a
pawn is upon not but I think it's it's
about equal with a lot of perspective
for white but then there is another
possibility after Bishop D2 here you can
simply Play Bishop D7 and once again the
Knight is going on C2
and black can take this pound with
absolutely the same typical plane play
from on White's behalf so you will
Castle let's say you can play Knight G7
here I will castle and you will have to
retreat your queen now absolutely don't
want to get it trapped Queen B6 yeah
and white continues but remember now you
have a lot of active moves you can bring
your king uh to G5 and then a few Castle
consider a computer already is looking
for the move like King f8 these are bad
news for you yeah and that that sounds
like great compensation thank you uh
Almira uh turning our attention to our
defending champion from the Canary's
game she's up against Nana the number
one player from Georgia and it was a
Queen's Gambit decline I've had this
position in my tournament practice
literally for decades I I this is what I
do as black and
um mostly 90 of the time I would play
Knight b87. five percent Bishop E7
another five percent for Bishop B4 never
got attracted to the C5 I I usually uh
put that in advance and I'll come back
C5 later in the game I would tell myself
so Knight B8 to D7
I noticed that one Magnus Carlson
started playing this crazy move A7 A6
now this move was known long before
Magnus popularized it but at the time
that I was playing it was considered
that the bishop was poorly placed on E6
like many times when you have this
position a Carlsbad confirmation you put
your Pawn on C6 you Castle you put your
Rook on E8 and you wanted the half open
e-file so that you could also plant a
night on e4 the bishop on E6 interferes
with those plans so everybody said can't
do it can't put the bishop on E6 the
modern chess engine so there's nothing
wrong with the bishop on E6 it may not
be it is its most glorious but it's not
bad and Bishop E6 became popular again
notice this trend in a lot of openings
especially in Queen's Gambit A6 and even
H6
right and then with white we saw at the
world championship match H3 right yes
it's a trend
this is great so they invited the great
Victor kochner
to become a commentator wow I think he
was a commentator for one day or at
Gibraltar Gibraltar and I believe his
comrade in arms no pardon me uh it might
have been Tanya
uh they're commentating on a game and
Victor corcinoy who played the French
his whole life they come to the game of
Nigel short and white has just played
the the move Knight C3 and Victor goes
hmm very interesting what will Nigel
play Nigel played H7 H6 and Victor said
next game
that's it that's it I'm not going to
look at this what a what a lousy move H7
H6 but I think you have same reaction to
Ace
okay maybe what I wanted to say was a
very big surprise for me right here
canero played the move Bishop f
4 and I was like looking at that
movement and going really because again
the classic the classical players Almira
would say what are you doing you're
voluntarily doubling your pawns is this
engine approved well you're absolutely
right yes so first of all this is a very
rare guest in well in Practical play but
this line is uh well has been analyzed
during the past years so uh even
um first of all I wanted what I wanted
to say uh here of course the main moves
are Castle or queen situ right classical
player would always play this but
recently they found this move Bishop
before what is interesting about this
move and of course because the game
could uh evolve in to two directions but
here the world champion Magnus Carlson
at that time he didn't it's about the
structure where do you want to go so he
didn't like this idea of playing Bishop
before he takes A4 and he played Queen
E7 because he wants to take with the
queen on D6 you know and do not alterate
the structure because he thinks that the
Knight only five will be very strong and
this is indeed a very powerful Outpost
so the game continued against livon
Arena after Queen takes it was simply
Castle here because Levon didn't take
castle and H3 which
is more classical or to your eye
this these are new developments when uh
black take
on F4 it takes F4 Bishop G4 we are still
following modern Theory and then Queen
need to check like in the game and black
I think is forced to play King f8 here
because after king queen is seven Queen
is seven you are forced to have your
king only seven anyway and now the
Knight goes to E5 with temple and this
position is much better for white
so King f8 is
almost forced here
and then do we have a few games yes
Castle was played in the game so now
a few different options you can play C6
to strengthen the G5 pound and to
prepare Queen B6 or G6 because you will
always be you have to consider this idea
let's say you'll play C6 something like
this and black can lose the bishop so
you will be forced to give your Bishop
on F3 anyway so sometimes black play G6
here
well instead of C6
with a complicated play computer thinks
that white is slightly better but I'm
not really sure that this is a wise
choice against humpicanero
okay intriguing uh game to be sure I
I just don't like the double pawns for a
white but then again I'm very
traditionalist where Pawn structures are
concerned one game that has at least to
my eyes kind of blown up I mean I
suspect that it's all modern theory is
the game of Elizabeth page
the groom fell defense waxes and wanes I
will point out that so jeans I started
with three losses right right do you
think today she would choose something
very solid to try to make a draw yeah
can they losing streak no she comes in
with the groom felt exactly one of the
sharpest openings you can play with the
black pieces exactly really really
counter attacking us swashbuckling
defense uh usually very very popular in
open events I must say I see a lot of
grunfels in open tournaments Swiss open
tournaments but in the
tournament around Robin the closed round
robin and the match play grunfeld is
considered a little bit a little bit too
much Bishop E3 I remember world
championship match between gelfand and
Anand yes they played a lot of
Greenfield exactly yes then because
Bishop E3 became popularized is by
Anatoly karpov and the idea was
counterintuitive was to put the Knight
on F3 traditionally in the 50s 60s they
put the Knight on E2 so that it didn't
get pinned but karpov revised this and
came up with a lot of intriguing ideas
one idea that karpov liked to do is to
play the move Rook B1 what's the idea he
wants to force the trade of queens and
if you played the move A7 A6 you can
play Rook C1 and his idea is actually
the poem stands worse on the A6 Square
than the A7 Square because there could
be a future where the B6 square is
weakened especially
on a trade and Knight takes D2 in any
case uh Rook C1 immediately and the
players quickly achieved this
double-edged position and after I saw
the move Knight F6 I must admit I I'm
not familiar with this line uh I did not
see the move D6 and I was thinking to
myself my goodness what is white going
to do to protect his D5 Pawn The
Bishop's hanging if the bishop
Retreats you you better have a a good
way of meeting Knight takes D5 If you
defend the bishop Knight D2 well I mean
could even consider grabbing a pawn the
move D6 well that's a tactical way to
defend yes
exactly so D7 D6 King h8 renewing the
threat to the bishop uh I suppose Bishop
E6 must be 32 right
you would think so but let me ask Almira
what's going on in uh well I to my eyes
it's double edged but then again the
theory marches each and every day right
uh yes yes sir I actually had a look at
the database and a lot of games in this
position while it appear extremely Sharp
and in a draw because there's always a
forced line somehow you know where the
players cannot improve on their position
so after D6 the best move in this
position is actually King h8 wow yes
that was the move which was made in a
few games and then uh you play Knight G5
that's how you protect your your bishop
and if you play H6 white can play H4
that's that's the way for you to keep
your knight on G5 so you can you cannot
take of course on G5 this will give a
Devastation attack to to wait so right
it's completely lost here of course so
after Bishop G6
there was one game after these six where
they actually played Knight D4 so Queen
C4 check it was the game between you
young you and widget on a very top level
so it also ended in a draw so even a
high complicated position maybe some
some how leads to a very balanced
position lately so after this King h8
so Queen A4 Bishop F5
Queen D5
and queen A4
Knight G5 with the game like this I
don't know how I turned it in a draw so
probably with the same a lot of ideas
which were played but I think that uh
this is already rather balanced after
Queen C6 so as you can see if you
exchange a few pieces here it decreases
uh the well European species pieces
potential and the position becomes very
calm right a quick question if you don't
mind me asking after the move D6 I
appreciate that the Oracle likes the
move King h8 and sets up night but you
know I I gotta ask I I'm grabbing the
two Bishops
and grabbing a pawn and so Knight takes
E4 you've got to give me a check to
recover your piece the king would now go
in the corner Queen takes now I always
have Bishop F5 as a Tempo in my pocket
but I was thinking well I've seen many
groomfelds where they grab this Pawn on
A2 and they say something like catch me
if you can uh challenge is as this been
played before is this Theory or uh
what what what's the what's the verdict
so it's like we I don't have any games
no games ah the rather games maybe on
the leeches I have to try in this
database because I myself do not
probably there are three games there is
a correspondence database which I did
not consult with after Queen A2 the best
move is simply to Castle right
yes and then uh well white is way ahead
in the development and I think this is a
very important factor in computer
assessments I think it compensates for
the two pounds and your queen on A2 is
so you'll have to bring it back so let's
say queen F7 okay it's a very natural
move I think so
um which Rook yes sir I I don't know
this is an existential question or maybe
Queen H4
the the line that nimsovich always gave
is no matter what Rook you chose the
correct answer was wrong Rook
which which Rook do you bring to D1
wrong Rook you know whatever it is yeah
wrong so what do you think about this
position
um
I don't know I mean you like it very
passive it's temporary but it's two
Bishops it's a pawn you still I mean
it's one of those things if you prove
your attack
the Bravo every everybody's happy with
you but if it goes wrong you'll resign
you'll resign you will you will die but
Elizabeth I didn't play Knight G5 no she
didn't she went D6 King h8
showed us my G5 with H4 ideas right
Knight G5 H6 H4 as Amira pointed out
there's been a number of games that's
preceded in this fashion also a little
bit you know dodgy and weird if you will
uh but Bishop G5 and this move I find
this move to be actually the most
challenging because from White's point
of view if I take then I've got control
of E4 forever you know like it's going
to be very hard for you to dislodge that
and by the way this Pawn has not been
captured it's still on the board so
Bishop G5 Challenge and what is the um
the theory on this one uh Almira well
here I do have three games let's have a
look after Bishop G5
black is probably almost forced to take
only four Queen A4 and I like this next
move Queen A6 first of all I prevent you
from castling and I'm not taking on it
too actually I'm attacking the D6 found
it's this is a very important Warrior
that I need to neutralize so Bishop E7
seems logical here we are still
following those three games Rook F4
queen of three
Bishop F5 development and threatening
and Rook E4 of course you you cannot
Castle this is a very important threat
but the computer still evaluates this
position is equal every game ended in a
draw you have to play Knight G2 here
in all of those games black played King
G8 they brought the king closer to the
action Queen C5 I have the suspicion
that a lot of these games were inspired
by correspondence analysis because this
position is way too complicated even for
us to understand immediately right so
Queen D3
and this is the first line of the
computer Queen E3 and queen A6
wow uh yeah yeah
it's not the slow patterns that I'm used
to burning yeah or maybe Queen is three
here is also closer what's more shocking
the moves like King G8 that all every
player played King G8 or that all these
games ended in a draw yes
surprising yeah like bringing your king
closer to the action like what what but
maybe there is somewhere down the line
there is an improvement right
one of the things that I've always felt
about the grunfeld which it shares in
nature to this vashnikov
generalities
don't rely upon generalities for those
uh positions it's really calculation and
grunfels and special costs
require great calculation by the way
again I have an another game with a Pawn
on this I was about to say take a look
there's an echo going on in Elizabeth
Bates game a white Pawn on D6 but in the
game of harika against gunai we have the
same thing uh very different opening but
white Pawn is still also on the sixth
exactly uh the slab defense it's been uh
one of the
venerable uh defenses for uh hundreds of
years this is called the classic system
yeah the classical's uh uh slav castles
Queen E2 a world championship matches uh
I'm thinking specifically of kramnik and
topolov they really analyze these
positions uh deeply takes takes Rook D1
Queen C7 E4 E5 D5 Bishop takes D7 D6
again one of these uh very a deeply and
analyzed opening theoretical positions
that don't rely upon general knowledge
or something like oh you're double pawns
oh your king is vulnerable or something
of that nature two Bishops versus two
knights with a pass Pawn on D7 pardon me
on D6
it requires calculation so even in this
position there's still Theory oh yes no
I'm looking and I can see databases uh
databases Galore I'm assuming Queen A5
uh is how most of these games go
um
you're are you do you like the knights
do you like the Bishops depends on the
position depends on the position yeah
but in Prince in general General Bishops
yes okay because Vichy is one of the
very very few one of the very few grand
Masters in the world that has really
throughout his career
enjoyed the nights and in this
particular situation uh well you've got
the Bishops you've got to pass on you
think uh lies good but
asset or liability right is the Pawn on
D sect yeah
I I'm ashamed uh my favorite piece is
the night okay why are you ashamed
because I prefer the bishop over the
night even though while I recognize that
the Knight is my favorite piece why
because of its unusual movements right
everything else's files diagonals files
diagonals files diagonals so you like
that it's Unique absolutely and its
ability to jump its powers uh make it
unique to any other piece and how there
are so many Charming positions where the
Knight Forks the king and the queen oh
yeah that just makes it so so
Amira your favorite piece knight or
Bishop well I love your conversation I
love the Bishops but you know that when
I Was preparing against uh Natalia
zhukova when we were playing a very
important game I realized that she loved
the night so much that it was one of the
most unique features for her evil in
chess so I based my preparation upon the
positions where I can exchange those in
it was a very good strategy so yes sir
now I know what I have to do against you
okay go for it yeah so let's have a look
at this position and yes sir I think
that you would like it especially
because here you can grab a few pounds
more so they're still following the game
sergeyson Fury right and as it was right
so after uh D6 Queen A5 right yes the
move B takes C3 here black has this very
aggressive move B5 so back in the bishop
you have to retreat because of course uh
this uh this Pawn is pinned so Bishop A2
then
I think it was Bishop A3 and then here
Queen C3
with a very complicated play which
computer evaluates once again is equal
so Bishops or knights in this position
it's up to you to decide absolutely and
two extra pawns so this looks like a
position for you with a black right yes
yes yes sign me up sign me up and uh we
have a social media question uh putting
us on guard embrace yourself incoming
and this one is from chessful on Twitter
I like that handle can I steal it
a chessful the question is do you prefer
a certain chess piece and board style
yes is it difficult to play with a style
you don't like yes and what are the
worst uh pieces you have played with yes
I have the answers are you a premium
member no uh for me uh I love
Stanton design pieces I love the wooden
pieces I mean I played with plastic
pieces essentially my whole life
especially Blitz but I love the uh
luxury Woods
weighted pieces I think that they are
the professional you know the the the
choice of professionals if you will so I
like them and uh
yeah and here's obviously a lot of
designs I love the wooden boards uh the
canvas roll-up boards are great but I I
feel that that's really more for what do
you think about this one lovely exactly
Pleasant yeah exactly put that on your
living room table but completely
impractical you know wouldn't want to
play with it these are nice these are
very nice yeah they like yellow pieces
instead of white
no I didn't like and when I first yeah
there you go
hand-painted pieces yeah wow I like the
colors though and of course the walnuts
out of the Chess Hall of Fame yes so
many beautiful colors pink and blue and
mixture of all in look at this I love
this but I would have to learn which
pieces which
uh the king is free so well there you
have it and here here are the uh House
of Staunton designed uh by Frank
camerata by the way just marvelous
marvelous stuff
um when I started playing chess I don't
know how the rumor developed but my
friends
discovered I mean family friends
discovered that I play chess so like I
don't know it was like a Christmas or
something I got the Milton Bradley black
and red checkerboard you know like they
had the checkers and the chess set and
the rules are like one page how to play
chess and the pieces of these incredibly
Hollow plastic I mean the the cover the
box cover looks great it looks like
you're you're in some wonderful uh great
struggle of War but they are easily the
worst pieces ever you know and I got
like three presidents
the worst pieces ever like I mean give
me a break it was really really really
bad the other thing uh and today it's
become less of a a deal like today we
don't even really think about it we all
use digital game timers dgt glugs but in
my day
the analog clocks we really love the
large wooden clocks you know like they
almost looks like tanks they were these
big clocks as a uh opposed to the quick
yeah the cheap PhD black stick wind up
so I really like not only the wooden
sets but the wooden cloths today you
probably never even played with a BHB
you don't even you know you're used to
looking at the clock and saying I've got
six seconds yes I was looking at the
clock saying when is the flag
I remember those because when I first
started playing in Georgia when I was
six or five six years old we had the
same wooden clogs and you couldn't tell
if you had five minutes left or five
seconds right it was like a weird
mechanism on the flag But to answer one
of your questions one of the most unique
chess Sports uh and chess pieces I've
played on was at the Chess Hall of Fame
couple years ago with Elisa malahina we
had this match where both sides were
same color so white it was white for
both yeah the uh trust right and Yoko
Ono I actually liked it neither of us
got confused we knew whose piece was
what what and it just shows that for
chess players at the end of the day it
doesn't matter what pieces we play with
exactly as long as it's just exactly I
played with Maurice Ashley the same set
and I'm just going to show quickly on my
board what we did so just as you were
saying
both white pieces and the black pieces
were white yes and exactly same exactly
the same right and I was white against
Maurice Ashley and
he played like this you remember the
game yes and uh he he went here
I castled he went here I played rookie
one he played E5 now keep in mind
all the pawns are white all the pieces
are white and I played E5 tape
and he said you can't do that
you're wrong
I'm not keeping it you eventually
managed to trick him
no the game stopped right there he said
I'm not I'm not continuing this game I
said wait I've got another idea here I'm
not finished with you yet come back no
but that was pretty pretty funny sorry
we got off track uh Amira
your favorite worst sets did you ever
come to an open tournament where you
faced an opponent who brought some
customized piece of garbage
and said your turn
not yet not yet I'm looking forward
you've got a place
this unique situation but I was thinking
that one of the most unique chess sets
that I have ever seen was done by men
Ray and I've seen and played on the
original you know this I was a very very
afraid to touch the pieces so if you
have a chance I think that you might
catch it on an exhibition one day but
it's very rare that it's even exposed so
but if we come back to this to our
tournament leader having a crash uh they
came I was actually right I think that
Arena hesitated and she decided to not
to play Queen B6 and queen B2 because
this position does not suit her style
right and especially with black I think
first of all you need to equalize and
then uh to play uh to look for counter
play if the opportunity will present
itself so I think that let me have a
look this is the position on the board
Bella just played A4 and
well very few games it's a very rare
move so I try to understand that first
of all
white is keeping the bishop on G3 black
should never take on G3 let's say uh
even after A4 I think that Bishop g38
David G3 it exposes you to a lot of
possibilities uh of the attack so you
should be careful with those moves so
black is usually keeping the bishop on
D6 and he's waiting for white to take on
the six here there are
plethora of possibilities and I thought
what if instead of A4 why Bella didn't
play E4 because it seemed to me uh well
like a quite natural move so let's say
something like this queen A4 G6 and even
along Castle is possible this is
this can show you how the game can
develop later Bella decided to play A4
she's uh she's still postponing her own
castle but I doubt that she will be able
to Castle along now but she's still
expecting for arena uh well to trade the
Bishops black has to wait so what move
can you make here you can play with
reverse colors you can play Knight F7
with the idea of playing Knight F5 or
Knight G6 but maybe here E4 is even
better so it's better timing you can
play Rook C8 you wait once again
but now maybe Knight E5 is a very strong
move so you even though the computer
still likes the position uh very much
for black so maybe there are a few
options after Queen C7 I don't know F4
is the very tricky move but I don't know
if you're going to make it but maybe
Bella wants to play something like this
but Irina actually played Queen E7 after
A4 so we have a move or not yeah
Queen okay I don't have a move yet so
let's try Queen you can see if I'm a
beautiful camera angle there the World
Chess Hall of Fame Queen E7 on the board
this variation is very rare and I don't
have a single game in the database so
this is officially a novelty and it
seems to be a very natural move what is
interesting is the computer suggestion
here
he wants to pin you Bishop H4
so it would be very logical for black
after Queen S7 to play E5 I think that's
the idea yes so E5 D takes C5 Knight T5
here take right yes take and Knight F3
with a Tempo but the position is still
more or less equal it's probably the met
the matter of taste if Irina likes her
position or not right
exactly
if it suits yeah if it suits her yeah
exactly for me uh I'm looking at the
game of harika and gunai again a very
very sharp theoretical dispute there's a
Pawn on D6 Queen A5 you spoke about this
Almera a number of games and including
farrugia takes takes and here again a
number of games played until Rook B1 and
then suddenly everything disappears it's
got a clean uh slate on my screen and
Novelty Rook B1 so previously I think
crook A3 was played Rook A3 was the main
move uh gaining a Tempo it's more
natural
it kinda does but on the other hand you
know you just what you just you just
attacked
yeah this is where I'm actually starting
to wonder can I get even more greedy
like I mean I'd like to uh I like to win
some time if you will Knight to B6 not
just to grab this Pawn maybe to bring
them we'll give you that pawn I'm gonna
go Bishop B3 Bishop David three B3 B3
this should be you're not going to give
me the problem pardon me I I thought you
were going to be generous and a nice
person
and all that good stuff so can I just
like
I'm gonna I'm gonna be really awfully
awfully greedy and I'm really gonna try
to win the pawn
um Bishop I almost have an option to
play Bishop A3 and depend upon that way
I'm also threatening D7 at some point
right
we don't have a move could I played the
queen A5 after Rook B1 Rook B1 she just
dropped back with her Queen and said uh
you're welcome she's been uh very nice
and generous person
well rugby seven uh maybe she's got it
in her mind that it's a fork right
there's a knight coming to C5
um upon on A4 is on tap but also this
Pawn on e4 if we ever land a knight on
e4 uh alert there is a fork uh rugby one
novelty what does the Oracle uh say
about this move Rook B1 because we
already have the answer Queen A5 did
good night make the right choice Almira
well Rook B1 is of course Innovative but
it is also the first line of the
computer so it's very easy really those
Novelties of course so uh previously uh
there was a move Rook A3 which was
played in one of the games so after okay
three uh
you have to play Queen before right then
F3 was played and then Knight B6 but
it's this very dangerous really I don't
know what you're going to do with your
queen on before so
um you are holding we are walking on the
thin ice yes this is the the expression
but yes rugby one is uh considered to be
even better after Queen's history by the
computer so Rook B1 Queen A5 you can
actually uh sorry that was the move that
you Queen A5 you can take on B7 let's
say after Knight C5 I analyzed uh Bishop
D2 here that's the suggestion you have
to take yep you have to take here the
computer suggests Rook B2 and the
evaluation is already plus five so yes
it is it means that you are going to to
lose your queen on the next move yes
rugby two a very important inclusion and
your queen is gone so you cannot explain
Knight C5 here I think it will be logic
call to play after Rook B7 Queen A4
maybe and try to survive here okay so
let's see what computer says I didn't
even have time to analyze queenly Force
so what is the difference if we play
Rook B2 here and then He suggests Knight
B6 tickling yes and you can no longer
retreat your Bishop here because you're
pounding E4 is saying it so this is the
key actually to this line so maybe after
after Queen A4 you need to protect first
your Pawn you will play F3 and you keep
all the threads on the board
wow uh amazing and in their head-to-head
matchup
uh they only had two games not much of a
database Erika won one and they drew the
other one okay so this is uh third time
here
um wow I the first of all that that that
valuation when the Oracle went to plus
five I wow I didn't imagine that Black's
position was so bad at the moment so
we're looking at Rook takes B7 very
natural looking move Queen takes A4 with
the idea of booting the bishop we want
to go Knight B6 take the pawn and the
move F2 F3 is the main lines of play
um it's not that obvious that white
needs to play F3 not at all so many
options and you still have undeveloped
Bishop you're slightly concerned about
the rookon B7 because it can I'm very
concerned about the Rook on V7 actually
yeah you can get attacked or even
trapped after 9p6 exactly to just defend
the E4 Pawn that's already defended at
the moment right I would if I were in
black shoes I'd really be seeking to to
get that Rook out a Dodge maybe
something like Rook B8 if you want to
trade Rooks that's fine you might want
to play I don't know Bishop B3 you might
want to play Rook C7 try to maintain The
Rook but that Rook really does bother me
and I would want to trade off the active
piece by the way I noticed that herika
has not jumped on the B7 Pawn she seems
to be really considering her options
here I suppose she's looking at Bishop
D2 and where's she could play F3 now now
F3 now wow same idea similar stuff
um is she is she thinking that she could
drive the black queen away so for
example Bishop D2 if you go Queen takes
A4 she might be saying
uh something about this position and
maybe the queen gets trapped I'm not
really too sure but uh Queen H3 oh sorry
yeah we'll just continue that line for
just a moment Queen A3
now how how could I round them up
uh Queen you can repeat with Rook V3
well all I would I I've got it in my
mind if I could play you know like Rook
A1 I could trap the queen so somehow
Queen
E1 it's weird am I trapping the queen I
don't know I don't know I I mean if I
don't catch you I'm gonna be a number of
puns down can I play A5
A5 and you forced me to take okay so now
my queen is
careful three I'll uh
um I was hoping he would play Rook A1
oh yeah no that would be uh that'd be a
lot of material right before and Pawn on
A3 and two Rooks and a passer uh I like
black in in in that case
um but harika is thinking Almira what is
she thinking about
maybe she's trying to remember her lines
because I doubt that the highly trained
professional will enter this line uh
without analyzing it thoroughly and uh
quite deeply so I I really think that
well she's hesitating probably which is
the first move F3 or Rook B7 because
both of them are very useful and
possible in this position uh I try to
follow your analysis here uh you can
trap the queen unfortunately and even
here you don't have the repetition
because you cannot play Rook B3 because
I can take the pound on D6 so
white could be in Dire Straits you need
to be very precise here so I tried yes
sir line after Queen A3 here Queen A1 so
A5 is a very good move suggested by a
nice day so of course after Rook A1 you
simply take one before and uh black is
winning yes so here that was the idea
behind the movie five so after Rook B7
you have this uh very nice move Knight
C5 not only attacked The Rook but I also
attacked the pawn and E4 so as you can
see in many variations they're all very
different but your opponent E4 needs to
be protected so maybe harika is thinking
what is the position where I need to
play F3 but she doesn't remember it
should I take on B7 then I play F3
should I play F3 immediately I think
that
this if I can explain what is going uh
through her mind this should be it
that very good well thank you uh Almira
before we go on break let's just first
refresh what's going on between our
tournament leaders uh let's take a look
at the game uh Bella and Arena when we
left it it was 8284. this London uh
system with Queen E7 and the discussion
turned right here Bella has facing a a
well a key Crossroads should she play
the move Bishop H4 uh establishing a pin
on the Knight on F6 but allowing E5 but
allowing E5 uh as an answer or should
she be playing a kind of Harry Nelson
Pillsbury uh attack with the Knight
coming to E5 followed by the move F2 F4
the Pillsbury attack was also an early
favorite of mine I really liked
establishing my knight on The Outpost
playing F2 F4 and going for the Rover
this kind of position by the way also
begs a question should I be castling
long very well if I want to go so long I
wouldn't have played A4 or should I be
castling short uh so Bella's got some
issues here I would like to see her play
95. I think that would be a great uh one
let's check in with Alexandra because
the players well in the case of Anna
zutanski of course we're going to expect
her to play slowly but so has
um
Alexandra in this French
with the early Knight A3 common enough
that the Knight is seeking to go to C2
just to reinforce the pawn on D4 takes
tags Bishop to D7
um in principle although you you get a
speedy development Bishop takes A3
normally black isn't so anxious to give
up uh the bishop so quickly oftentimes
Bishop B4 check is preferred over Bishop
takes A3 Bishop D7 Bishop E2 and times a
factor well and it's been thinking for a
while she's down to 48 minutes and
Alexandra still has one hour and 22
minutes and I will point out that this
is only eight moves on the board right
yes that's what I meant when I said
they've both been playing rather slowly
uh here I would expect a move like 97
followed by Knight F5 and or the early
attacking uh moves F7 I liked your
Bishop B4 idea as well also to just
relieve a little bit the pressure the
the pawn on E5 is a cramping influence
and oftentimes uh trading pieces is a
very good idea against a
um an advanced Center as we get ready
for a break it's always a good time to
check in on our dear friends at Q
Boutique and to see what the daily
special is
let me tell you what's going oh it's on
tap for today St Louis chess club the
puffy vest here we go gear up the newer
newest apparel from the St Louis chess
club with this original official pardon
me branded puffy vest features the chess
club signature logo across the left
breast pocket and I'll see them and look
at this
okay here you go yesterday so if you
could throw it to one of them about how
awesome it is for an additional moment
okay yeah well I'm gonna do it I'm
reading this thing and I'm supposed to
be tell asking you like what what what
how did you like it Almira
okay well very very nice and it's
available only at Q Boutique St
louis.com do check it out for all of
your chess shopping needs and we'll see
you on the other side of the break
[Music]
how does it feel to be here in San Luis
for the Third Edition of the Karen's cup
yeah I'm very happy I played first one
and after after a break we are playing
like 31 and very happy to be part of it
it's the strongest tournament in the
world with huge price on and I'm really
glad to be invited
um it feels good it's my first time in
us and in St Louis so I really love the
atmosphere and I really love the venue
so I do look forward to play as soon as
possible
well it's great I was actually surprised
when I got the invitation because for
the second tournament I I didn't and I
was really upset so when I saw the email
I was very happy and I and I mean I told
to my parents like okay
yeah I'm very excited and I think this
time it's a quite a different field with
a lot of mix of end players as well and
definitely this is one of the strongest
women tournaments and also with the
highest price fund ever
so I think it's going to be quite tough
for everyone I'm so happy to be back
here I mean I'm so happy that the
Karen's cup has resumed after a couple
of years you know um of a break for the
for the pandemic and um yeah it's a very
special tournament I mean it was kind of
formulated to be one of the strongest
tournaments for women in the world and I
think it's going to be super exciting
I'm always very excited when I'm getting
invitation from Saint Louis and I'm
really very glad that I'm still here
after three years of break and yeah I'm
looking forward for a wonderful
tournament I'm really excited because
after three years we all are here and we
understood the value of it after
pandemic and to give importance that we
are here all healthy and playing the
tournament so definitely I'm really
excited that the strongest ornament
clearance cup is back with the Third
Edition and yeah I'm looking forward to
be part of it so it's a long time time I
cannot do not been here it was 2018. my
first visit to Saint Louis and I had
very good Memoirs despite of my playing
so I hope I hope that this year will be
more
interesting games for me and
um I think well very well here I'm
delighted to the time here because I
like this club very much and this
atmosphere everything it's
um it's really nice
it's over here again
um first of all like I was very happy to
receive the invitation almost in the
last moment because I think I was one of
the last participants to join the event
but yes I remember my time in 2019 even
so I think back this time I got the last
place not sure but I think so
um this time I hope I will do a lot
better I mean at least like to get
somewhere in the middle would be nice
and yes I am very happy that when I came
here today that I could recognize so
many things so nothing really changed
and it's still the same Spirit like
looking at the hall of fame
so I'm really excited to start actually
I'm very very happy and very excited I
was very looking forward to coming back
because we had this
um three year long Gap and you know
every single year we like got emails
about the possibility to be back and
then somebody didn't quite work our way
so I'm very relieved to be back and I'm
very looking forward to playing again
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our standings after round three we
have two co-leaders Alexandra Carson you
can Irina crush and in the clearer third
amazonski and Anna and Alexandra are
playing each other as we speak so that
is just a huge match going on right now
some uh breaking news in our game uh
that was between Elizabeth
uh that that super super sharp groomfeld
Amira was saying a lot of the times the
lines go into a very very forcing
sequences that end in a draw well guess
what that's pretty much what we're about
to see after the move Queen A6 Queen D5
Bishop D7 Knight takes E5 you you think
well you can't do that because I'll get
you on the e-file I do have this bishop
dropping in the way on E7 so the line
goes Rook F5 Knight F7 at first blush
you think oh Black's in Gray trouble
until you see this move Queen D3 and
basically that's an invitation for a
Perpetual check is coming exactly Rook
takes E3 is coming takes takes and uh
because the Rook is hanging I'm gonna go
King D1 and I can imagine the players
will be making a draw very very shortly
uh let's go to uh a marquee match of
between two of our tournament leaders so
when we left it we left it at this
position Bishop to D7 more familiar I I
want to say with the move Knight C2 than
I am with Bishop E2 Bishop E2 Bishop B4
check now the desirable Bishop D2 simply
blocking the check would allow Knight
takes D4 which is why
but white has to move her King now after
King uh F1 Knight C2 is going to come
with the tempo against the bishop well
Anna said well let me take your knight
and we have uh caught up to the play
Knight A5 to my mind what
uh black is Desperately Seeking is to
trade off her passive Bishop for this
active Bishop take control over the C
file and we're still in theoretical
Waters Nazi yes we're just discussing
this during the break how this position
looks like White's Pawn structure is
pretty bad and we're trying to evaluate
who's better and then we realize oh this
is still Theory exactly Queen D3 uh uh
Alexandra
I was about to say that's a but I I I
understand it in the sense that from
White's point of view it should be five
white would love to play Rook B1 the
only problem is the rook's not defended
and she wants to stop Bishop B5 so it's
kind of a move that you think to
yourself oh I can kill two birds with
one stone Ken black just play A6 and
still threaten Bishop B5 and I think
that's what fuel likely will do now as
we weren't on break Almera I I saw the
game between Bella and Arena and I
thought Bella had played the move a2a4
solely with the purpose of just delaying
any kind of a pond storm on the queen
side but no she had a very specific idea
she wanted to follow up with upon
sacrifice
[Laughter]
actually I liked your move Knight F5 I
think is one of the best options in this
position right in this type of position
so uh in the computer hesitates
black just played Queen E7 and after
knight uh sorry Knight E5 here he
proposes Queen C7 interesting it's a
very strange maneuver indeed uh
yes and we do have the repetition we
spoke about as we came back from break
um Elizabeth
a draw and they've agreed to address
please continue uh Almira uh 95 was a
computer's move but about this move A5
is this is very unusual yes it's a very
unusual idea especially here so let's
say should you first change the
structure take on A5 because if you take
on the five I was thinking what happens
if you take on C5 right how should you
take here Easter's Bishop C5 than you
have B4 and you win a piece clear so uh
black has to decide Arena has to decide
here uh should she take on D4 first then
maybe e takes D4 and then Knight E5 but
computer thinks that white is slightly
better but maybe now that the Knight is
only five you can play
95 comfortably
so what do you do here
after Knight E5 you you have to react
yeah presumably I come back with a
knight on A5 back to C6 yes let's say
Knight C6 but then this move
is already much stronger because you no
longer you can no longer play E5 you
cannot take on E5 because you will lose
a piece simply and of course Bishop B5
also is not possible because you will
lose a piece once again so maybe this is
Bella's idea okay so 95 go ahead put
that on the board so Knight D7 the
sidestep bishop H4 to let's say 97 uh
the computer suggests that the position
is fairly equal even though weight is
the pound down and I suspect because
this bishop is very active and his peer
the more I was looking for another day
is very passive and you will deal with
this uh for quite a while so after Queen
D7 the computer says simply castle and
he really likes the option of giving the
pound back and opening your Bishop on B7
and now he thinks that black has solved
all its opening problems wow that the
way the computers just throw the pawns
back and forth through so our results as
far as the first game in the history
books round four the one game finished
and it was a drop between Elizabeth pet
and Jean Saya Abdul Malik exactly and
for for
um I'm not gonna say Abdullah
she's on the scoreboard yes chapter
three yeah after three losses uh welcome
back uh there
um so that that was Arena's game and by
the way I I wanted to say just with
Arena's game because again if I'm
thinking of A4
pardon me yeah if I'm thinking that
White's playing A4 to stop
um black from making a pawn storm
let me play the move C4
so you still want to so yeah I I I want
to avoid the D4 take C5 business that
Elmira is showing us you know with B4
and I want to say okay you know I I took
upon so I'm keeping this Pawn on E3 so
yes you can go 95 but maybe you're not
getting that the beautiful uh Pillsbury
attack that you want with the pawn on E3
and later in life I'll go back and I'll
make my Pawn storm what do you think
about that as a pawn sacrifice would you
go C5 C4 I think I would because like I
said I like to start a counter play
right I'm a little worried about 95 and
F4 and all this because as well as maybe
bishop H4 and that's the key here
because Aaron I chose to put the queen
on E7 instead of C7 which I normally do
right I don't like that pinbish of H4
exactly I hate being pinned myself okay
uh we'll continue our look around our
defending champion
versus Nana when we left it the players
had gotten to this very
um well I I want to say
intriguing for me decision of Bishop F4
voluntarily doubling up your pawns as we
as we were told by Almera Magna no less
a player than Magnus himself did not
capture on the on F4 preferring Queen E7
well the most challenging Nana said I'll
I'll take up that challenge she took
played Bishop G4 and queen E7 check C7
C6
castles okay kings are on opposite
flanks at the moment so 94 rookie one
takes takes Queen Bishop G4 Knight F6
rookie 5 G6 we're up to date with the
players I just wonder where we left
Theory by the way
just uh I'm gonna go over to O'Mara and
ask where where was the novelty in this
game because it's a it's a double-edged
position uh Elmira I wanted to note a
funny moment here because there are
still a few games played in this
position and white played King F1 here
in a few of them so I really wanted to
show you that king of fun is also
possible here so you have the King on
the f8 and a king of on F1 but Bishop E2
was played there was only one game
played by Grand Masters and here Knight
B6 was played in this game so C6 is the
official novelty in this line okay and I
think that after Castle which was a very
good move in this position 94 Rook H1
he1 Knight C3 Queen C3
Queen D6 which is all very natural uh
and then we came back to this position I
think that white has a very strong grip
uh on this position even though it's
still materially balanced and you don't
have any weaknesses but I think is this
is very easy to play once again and
especially for Hanby conero um
intriguing and in their head-to-head
match-up they played each other a few
games
19 total games and Hopi has a lead with
seven wins wins over three wins but
mostly they've made draws yeah but
that's a convincing line score of seven
wins to against uh three losses by the
way
in that uh game in that analysis that
Amira was showing us where humpy plays
King F1 and visit King on f8 forcibly
reminded me of a variant proposed by
Vladimir kramnik you're not allowed to
Castle
you have to move your king So King F1
and King f8 uh the current position uh I
find this very intriguing because Amara
said you know white has a grip on the
position I put it a different way white
has a a nice Outpost of The Rook on E5
I'm thinking it's not so much a grip as
it is a question of
um uh vulnerability of the king and to
my mind when I see a a king over here on
the queen side I'm thinking open the
position open the you can do it yes
yeah play King G7 B6 C5 open up that C
file let's go and you know for me the
question is who's King you know you're
gonna yeah you're gonna land blows I get
it I see your I find this coming and but
I want to go C5 uh when evaluating the
minor pieces Knight versus Bishop I
prefer Knight in this position and I
think if Wyatt could switch the white
square Bishop to be in Black Square
Bishop oh yeah the darks were Bishop H6
yeah basically in closed positions or
semi-closed positions close positions or
when you have 16 pawns on the board some
semi-closed positions when you have 14.
generally favors the knights although
again specific but you're right I kind
of like the Knight on F6 for the moment
let's continue I'll just uh one game we
haven't checked is the hurricane and
only update is that harika did take the
pawn on B7 after a long think yes this
was the game where the Rook B1 uh
uh Queen A5
that Harry come was maybe considering
Bishop D2 yes because it was an
interesting move exactly but she decided
to take on B7 uh yeah renewing her
membership in the Palm grubbers Club
Rook takes B7 we were looking at Queen
takes A4 because remarkably Knight B6
bad things could end up happening to
Black's Queen we were looking at Queen
takes A4 and by the way both players
basically stopped uh at this moment uh
just before Rook B7
we understand special guests in studios
with you
uh thank you yes sir I'm so happy to
welcome today Trent Colquitt and
Associate at cubic and what I learned
that is the award-winning gift shop at
the vultures Hall of Fame welcome Trent
thank you so much for having me yes
please tell us a little bit about the
history of Q Boutique and what are your
best sellers there oh awesome well once
again thanks for having me the Q
Boutique is uh located inside the world
chest Hall of Fame and it is associated
with that as well so it has chess
related items such as pieces and DVDs
and books to help with chess but we're
all considered an all-season Boutique as
well so we have tons of other things
that will specialize for any guests
whether puzzles or games uh even cards
for like those those hard to gift people
so we have tons of those things as well
actually those places
for me tough for me because I want to
buy literally everything especially well
as a professional chess player I want to
to have all those things at home
there is always a new apparel for a
tournament please tell us about your
Novelties for the Cairns Cup oh awesome
yeah so typically for every single
tournament we have custom apparel
whether it is a t-shirt or a hat or
something to represent each of the
tournaments that we have here at Q
Boutique or here at the chess club as
well uh so for the Karen's cup we will
have some autograph boards and some uh
posters as well from the from the
tournament participants and I've also
learned rumor has it that you have a few
unique gifts at your cubic so tell me a
little bit about those so maybe sign
chess boards yeah and that's for every
tournament as well so for every
participant of every tournament that we
have we do have signed chess boards we
do also have some signed posters from
time to time but we do also have tons of
custom apparel you can get all of that
online as well as our brick and mortar
location
well so I invite all of you guys to
visit Saint Louis and queue Boutique I'm
pretty sure that we are going there on
the free day so we'll find something new
thank you so much and well one question
how well do you play chess and do you
follow the tournament daily so we're
gonna have the boutique we do get to
follow a lot of the live stream so it
has been really cool I started playing
probably around seven years old so I've
been playing a little bit I'm still on
an amateur level so I couldn't take on
any of these awesome ladies today but uh
I definitely enjoy watching it and yeah
that's one of the biggest reasons that I
work at the boutique now so oh it's
impressive thank you very much thank you
so much and back to you yes sir actually
Trent we got a question from a social
media or maybe it was just the ladies a
lot of the
um participants in the Karens cup have
been wearing their swag and the question
was could could
normal people buy the same hoodies that
the ladies were wearing
uh so what was that of the hoodies well
they were they're wearing uh these uh
the Karen's uh jackets oh yeah
absolutely yes they are available online
and at our Bricker motor location so
it's a cute boutiquestl.com oh yeah we
were told that they were exclusive
I told you they were exclusive
all right thank you Trent thank you for
joining us thank you thank you so much
right okay well now we know
I think you're asking because you want
one for yourself well you know there are
very special ladies in my life but uh
that if I come home empty-handed you
know how it works
um I just wanted to say there was a line
that caught my eye right here in the
game of Arena pardon me Nana sorry not
Arena Nana was the move G7 G6 right so
you know uh let's say King B1 normal
move right King B1 King B1 if I take
take
F6 you found a way to win a bot well not
quite because there is three three
I want to come down to E3 group to E3
um yeah with the King on C1 it was
actually even stronger so I played it I
played an awkward move I want to say
that that I don't know if black has a
threat or not right but it's this idea
like playing F6 and you do have this
kind of funny indirect defending move
Queen F3 to defend the pawn
um so I would have to play in the king
G7 and not be able to take the rook and
then your your rookie three so I I
didn't know if Knight takes G4S
is on tap or not just uh thinking about
it Almera over to you as uh well that
was nice to get our questions answered
about the apparel well I I'm certainly
looking for a few gifts in this shop
right I usually leave Saint Louis with
my suitcase completely packed right I
wanted to show you for example A3 is a
bit artificial to me but let's say I
will put another Rook on E1 it's very
sensible
you should be very careful once again
with those moves because the evaluation
skyrockets and if you play F6 it's
already
plus 5.8 wow so even even if you take
the spawn with a check I think that
after King B1 uh your King's safety is
um a very important factor once again
which you should we would say it doesn't
exist
the king safety no longer exists right
so it's no longer absolutely in this
position so G6 Rook E1 then I guess kpg
yes
um
you will this Rook is going to stay on
E5 forever I suppose so you can make uh
another move you know like Queen S3 to
control the E file so even if you put
let's say which Rook once again it's the
wrong Rook yeah the wrong Rook
right anyway so let's say uh
and I was thinking uh this was my human
suggestion Bishop B3 because I thought
okay how should you continue once again
your pieces are an optimal Square so I
think maybe bishop F3 and G4 uh let's
see if computer likes it he says let's
see something maybe Rook C8
King B1
um now He suggests something completely
artificial for human eye Rook ed88 let's
say and G4 right you see this this is
probably a White's plan exactly well
again uh it's natural for me when the
kings are on opposite sides these moves
G4 F5 trying to make Black's King
vulnerable and for from Black's
perspective when the king is on B1 to
play B6 and C5 and let's let's go let's
go let's get going by the way I'd like
to turn our attention if you don't mind
just to the game of Bella and arena for
just when I say you're going to be happy
once you see that Arena took your advice
she did play C5 C4 and then she grabbed
the point and she grabbed the pawn and
then you're saying yourself that okay
you like what arena is doing but there's
a consequence whether it be Knight E5
and or Bishop H4
this is some music that we're going to
have to face and Bella started with the
move Bishop H4
um and if I'm in in black shoes I
understand that you want to play the
move E4 right I really do I get that
um but I'm thinking because your king is
still in the center
maybe I can play a little bit uh
devilish E5 E5 uh throwing it out there
to yeah take the taxi Bishop takes my
takes no he takes and this is what I
wanted to say yeah I I'm relieved I'm
relieved uh that I know we may have new
problems okay I went from one problem to
another problem I I got out of the pin
but I didn't necessarily so yes my
issues you opened up D file and
especially D4 Square for my knight yes I
did very good that's a nice Outpost
where are you gonna move the queen now
that's my that's the problem I'm really
having I don't have a complete I don't
have a convenience Square Queen D6 again
I don't want to Queen E7 might be okay
but walking right back into it why did I
play E5 if it wasn't my my whole
intention had been to avoid the pin okay
I'm thinking you know okay maybe I can
go 94 Knight D3 oops that was supposed
to be Knight B3 folks I don't know how
it'll yeah I mean you have an extra Pawn
you got out of the pan in but white has
a pair of Bishops great outpost on D4
possibly a Target on D5 yeah it's more
like I'm never going to win that pawn
but you're going to have to be defending
it for the rest of the game agreed by
the way Arena dealing with the pin she
dealt with it in a completely different
way she she said
I'm gonna put my Bishop in the way I'm
gonna play Queen d8 and Bishop E7 so I
assume after 95 Bishop E7 F4 she's gonna
kind of roll with the punches and
whether it be Knight C6 or maybe Knight
d8 she's saying show me your
compensation uh prove that your attack
is worth upon and she's got a point yeah
she does that's right I would consider
since it's not my game yes I could
consider going crazy here I'm playing G4
right away
wow
I'm not really an aggressive mood today
what's happened uh yeah he's the you're
being inspired by these uh players yeah
I still want to cast along because now
that yeah well why did you move your
Pawn from A2
so you would castle with G5 or without
G5 you think about it okay castles
wow okay uh where where where
we're throwing uh throwing the patties
here Knight to E4
um your Pawn is on G4 I'm kind of happy
that you're missing the A2 bonus uh as
black
um take honey seven okay uh munch munch
and Knight takes E4 okay Munch Munch a
night D2
don't tell me you're trying to win your
Pawn back
you might be trying to win the fight but
if you do take the pawn on C4 you'll be
walking into a massive uh but I invite
you to play a five like I finally want
to open up the G file all right I'll
fall for it F5
um
probably okay you'll you'll tell me
later if um if we made uh some something
wrong I just wanted to make F3 work at
some point maybe
maybe now it's not complete you haven't
convinced me that you've got uh the the
compensation and who's attacking whom
here yeah I think my B4 am I getting
checkmated yeah yeah exactly I I might
be coming first I I appreciate the fact
that you've you're opening up the G file
but Arena uh Almera I mean Irene is on a
roll she's got two and a half out of
three this is her third game with the
black pieces reminding everybody she
started with two blacks uh
wow uh this is this is this is good
stuff
let me show you something please because
the more I look at this position uh the
more I'm thinking about something Divine
because the whole concept uh of White's
play is really very deep so first of all
why did she play A4 A5 because this
Knight is no longer available for any
defensive task so Knights is 697 96 so
this was the first step of uh of the
opening strategy now be sure Pitch Four
is a very important move I wanted to
show you a simple variation why Arena
didn't play E5 I think that maybe simply
because of this and then 95 Bishop B5
you have Bishop Queen H5 and well I
definitely win my Pawn back and you are
having your B7 Bishop uh in like on
there in the game and uh the computer
evaluates this position as much well
slightly much better for white and I
think very easy to play so Queen d8 is
really I didn't see Bishop F6 when I
proposed the ep5 I wasn't even
considering it actually counter in
swedes yeah that means that Bella knows
this position very well it's like when
uh Fabiano caruana took on C3 in the
king's Indian against redis love way
tashek and this revolutionized the whole
understanding of of this opening
especially in this position so let's
have a look Queen d8
I like this move G4 very much of course
black wants to and pin itself with
Bishop B7 so let's say G4 could be
played and once again let's say if you
play Bishop E7 here
this bishop F6 comes in handy once again
because you win so many temp Tempe here
and here H4
look at the computer's Evolutions he
thinks that's why it is slightly maybe
much better like in the long run so wow
um I'm not sure that Irina is feeling
comfortably here
and even 95 as possible here so your
king is actually safe here you don't
need to Castle Nazi I think that it can
stay here if you don't you can play four
maybe a bit later but for the moment you
certainly uh you will certainly
concentrate on Black's King wow uh G4 is
certainly a confusing move and their
lifetime matchups uh they've only played
seven times throughins for Bella two for
Irena and two draws so a side edge for
Bella against
it's interesting
for idea could work but you have to
follow up with Bishop F6 that's the key
move wow and you know when when you're
making these videos yeah exactly when
you're making these moves Bishop H4
opening midnight it's not like you're
giving up the bishop voluntarily but I
guess that's a key I think once you
realize how strong Knight E4 is in those
lines that we're looking at you realize
yeah it's better to just take them get
get rid of the bishop I'd like to turn
our attention to the our defending
Champion's game for a moment because
if I've got this right she just sat I
mean she achieved a position but this
the clock times uh she had to spend more
than one hour already uh unfortunately
20 moves and let's assume the first team
she more or less 10 moves or so she knew
oh I think she played it to Bishop F4
what was Bishop F4 move nine move nine
sorry yes so so on 10 moves she spent
about an hour
right right on on these parts right here
and uh okay we're up to date with the
Play Bishop F3
um for me I like this move King G pardon
me yeah King G7 Rook E1 I didn't know if
I needed the move Rook E8 or not that
it's like one of those things you're not
sure to my way of of thinking I really
really want to play C5
so I I'm not sure I want to play it with
an isolated Pawn so for me the moves B6
and C5 have to be uh put together one
problem when you do play C5 you're
opening up the A1 h8 diagonal yes and
unless you have D4 right away right your
king might be in trouble uh yeah I I see
that uh I could easily end up wide Place
G4 and then quickly G5 you might end up
yeah I could see yeah why how and why I
could get I got compromise very very
nastily by this so something to keep in
mind but this is such a big matchup uh I
I keeping my eye on this as uh we're
gonna jump to Almera who has a guest in
studio Almera over to you
thank you yes sir we have John Sayer
with us for the first time uh welcome
John said you had quite a difficult
start in this tournament and before we
analyzed the game a little bit I wanted
to ask you uh well how do you feel
because it seems like after you lose
well first three games it seems that
I personally think I will never win
again so uh tell us a little bit about
how you feel well yeah I mean it's it's
not good when you start tournament with
the losing three games but I mean okay
it happens I didn't play for a while my
last tournament was uh in the
February we played in Munich
so yeah
I don't know I'm just trying to stay
positive
since I ended there was a very important
well event in your life you got married
you know after the Grand Prix so do you
think uh well it will have an impact on
your play we were talking about some
Grandmaster were losing 50 points
somewhere winning 50 points no I think
okay maybe for now I'll lose them but
then I mean I'll get them back for sure
if I want it but okay now I'm busy with
other stuff but sure I'll be back so
it's fine does your husband support you
during the tournament he follows the
games yeah he follows the games even
though we have like 11 hours difference
so it's very important for me that he's
very supportive and also it's not easy
because I mean I think I'm staying here
for like two weeks already uh yeah
they're easy to not see each other you
know but it's fine okay okay so today
you you drew against Elizabeth pets uh
how difficult it's it is to play against
your friend first of all
well I honestly I don't like to play
against my friends because usually you
know you're you're kind to them and I
don't know what to do with it so yeah
it's kind of my weaknesses so I don't
like yes to play against my friends and
okay I'm trying to be like not that
aggressive okay so but you chose the
Greenfield today it's one of the most
aggressive openings but yeah but okay I
mean for the last time I didn't work
much and the Greenville is my main
opening so I thought like okay why not
to play the old stuff okay so here were
you surprised by the line that Elizabeth
uh choose today I think how far did you
know here to uh till which point I I'm
not sure if I remembered my line but I
saw some games maybe like years ago so I
was surprised after Bishop G5 oh here's
yourself yes I I didn't know this move I
knew that there was some games of Arena
crash I think it was from the Olympiad
And discussing yes after the game with
Elizabeth she also saw the game so she
wanted to surprise me with shot G5 but
oh yeah F3 Bishop G5
when I saw like taking on e4 and queen
A6 I think I was really fine with my
position because she she couldn't castle
and I thought like okay it's very
Dynamic and equal probably so it's fine
yes this this was played actually a few
times already and a white uh played
Bishop B7 several times in this position
were you considering this move yeah I
was checking I was checking some crazy
line with Rooker for
and I didn't know if it's like working
or not because then there is this idea
it was okay for this I knew and I look
at you and trying to give a maid on A2
on A2 yes so maybe bishop F5 is
something like this yeah maybe this
looks normal
so you were feeling quite confident here
anyway yes after Knight E4 yeah that's
actually what I like from Greenfield
because it's it's dangerous but I think
that's my style so I like to play this
crazy amazing position so that's fine
and how did it go oh yes it was the
repetition of the repetition and a very
complex position
uh
and with the Perpetual check so
you guys here I was saying you know King
F1 and just running but probably is also
draw what do you do after king of one
let's check if our computer says
something yeah I think I can yes we can
take the river
take the rook and you cannot Escape
so now that you've made the drawer
tomorrow you're going to be in a very
aggressive mood with white yeah against
Alexandria oh so you already know your
pairing sir you've prepared a little bit
uh yeah I prepared a little also we were
playing last year in the Grand Prix in
Australia and I lost with white but I
was like really well prepared but she
surprised me with within one move and
then it just went wrong so hopefully
like tomorrow will be much better yeah I
think you should say you know we never
talk about our feelings or emotions so
you told us about the game that you lost
with bite so are you seeking for Revenge
tomorrow
oh maybe but it's it's a this emotion it
can be very risky for me because I mean
I'm not in the best shape and if you see
my games like I'm trying to push and
yeah that's why I lost
I don't know what will be tomorrow but
okay I'll try my best okay lots of luck
for tomorrow and we hope to see you once
again thanks indeed lots of luck as
anxiety turning our attention to
Alexandra and uh Anna's game uh things
have taken a very intriguing positional
turn we left it after Bishop takes A3 B
takes A3 Knight A5 and exactly here the
move Queen D3 turns out to be a novel
move
um it it seems natural and the one way
we want to stop the bishop coming to B5
we would like to play the move Rook B1
with the tempo so Queen D3 seems to
accomplish both of those goals but it's
actually a novelty and it's probably
one of those where you kind of committed
your queen early uh type of things
normally speaking I liked your move Nasi
A7 A6 like you know again you want to
trade off this light squared Bishop
except for those times when the light
squared Bishop makes a great blockader
so and many winowers for example you see
a bishop coming to A4 and if the bishop
ever comes to C2 it's great sorry might
be one of those rare cases in the French
defense where blacks white square
Bishop's actually good exactly so you
don't have to exchange it right you you
you're not jumping at the the first
opportunity to get it off the board on
the contrary the two minor pieces the
bishop on A4 as well as the Knight on C4
they're making a very nice impression
asking why to very Salient question what
is your dark Square Bishop doing if your
dark Square bishop ever gets to uh B4
might just play A5 5 and B6 and Chase it
off the diagonal so I think the uh in in
a greater sense there's some pressure
now on Alexandra to justify her double
pawns and her play because if you just
let Anna develop her Knight whether it
be 97 Knight F5 or 97 Knight G6 Castle
black is going to say I'm happy camper I
was going to say that I think the next
couple of moves are very critical
because if black develops and castles
black will be better absolutely
absolutely so there you go
and by the way we're good here we go we
have a chess clock
the the question for our audience is to
whom does this clock belong
I think it's easy to guess I think it's
easy to guess when you think about
honesty in the playing Hall and what
color she might be I think by the way
our producer didn't realize that with
the bishop on a
the hint was too great Anna's down in
time uh in fact looked like a whole half
hour there but uh Bishop Knight C4
um help help Alexandra
out if you had this position as I guess
let's play rugby one since we played
Queen D3 with that idea too okay
everyone let's do it
uh rugby one uh let's I don't know I'll
move my queen you're making me play with
white yeah I'd much rather be back okay
well then we'll get our mirror to play
uh with uh White because we're we're
we're
kind of satisfied with Black's position
Almera
uh well I was thinking that it reminded
me of Bobby Fischer you know who played
for both colors you know that's exactly
what I'm doing here yes I'm trying to
understand you know all the intricacies
of this position right actually rugby
one is a very good move of course and
it's natural let's say you can choose
Queen C7 Queen C6 okay and here well
I've studied these positions a while ago
but uh the same is true for many uh
French structures very often you want to
play H4 yes this move and bring your
Rook HH to H3 Rook G3 but here beware if
you play each four immediately there is
a very nice tactical yes
Bishop C2 and if you take on situ there
is 93 that's how you understand that
first you need to prepare the move H4 so
after Rook B1 Queen C7 white has to play
a very strange looking move Road King G1
but now now you understand why actually
so first thing G1 let's say black will
develop the Knight
on E7 and then I will start with H4 so I
haven't made up my mind yet if black
should Castle here or not because
especially with so little time on her
clock and I will be facing a lot of
troubles here if well let's let's try
Castle oh immediately
1.8 yes yeah yeah yes you walked into
trouble exactly so even Knight G5 is
possible immediately here so you have to
be careful then you it means that you
cannot Castle immediately He suggests
it's a sheep Oracle so just Rook C8 or
H6 maybe to prepare the castle and maybe
she can continue with H5 here
do you like this position for white yes
sir or for black
this position I'm starting to like white
because I think the move Rook C8 that's
not to my liking uh first of all I love
what you were saying about Queen C7 I
have missed this a nice little tactical
shot Bishop C2 why did we think Knights
were our favorite pieces you know the
the the the Knight discovered check to
win uh it was very nice uh after King G1
Knight E7
H4 I would probably find myself playing
H6 and if you played H5 and or Rook H3
with both of my
minor pieces on
A4 as well as C4 uh locking up the queen
side I start to think that well you know
Knight C6 followed by uh castles lung
are you really gonna get my king I I
think it would be very very very hard to
mount a successful attack with so many
defenders in front of my king so I would
think that this is a three result game
frankly I whereas I'm thinking that in
the variation you you showed us Almera
where the Knight went to E7 the Palm
went to H4 The Rook went to C8 uh I
think the Rook you one pound one H5 now
I'm
now I'm thinking that the king I don't
want to go kingside I think I'm walking
into a uppercut and I don't want to
leave my king in the center either so
I'm thinking that for for for for uh
Anna
I I would like her to keep the flexible
castles long by the way she did choose
Queen C6 it was a question Queen C7 or
queen C6 I chose the C6 Square myself so
the thing about putting the queen on
cyst six is that in the future if you
want to play Knight E7 Knight C6 it's no
longer available agreed uh I don't yeah
and uh again this move Bishop C2 is very
very sneaky
a lot of players could easily fall for
that uh Alexandra
is she you know tactically alert and
aware that you know there is this well
would I could you call that a hidden
threat I think that Alexander is
tactically alert even when she's
sleeping
that's what I felt about Gary Kasparov
and in fact Tony Miles said he had a he
was a monster with 8 000 eyes it's like
he saw everything at the board he was
really really frightening Bishop C2 is a
a little bit of a surprise tactic keep
that in mind quickly checking in on
Arena's game because again she played G4
she's tied for first with Alexandra and
guess what took a page right out of your
book G4 Bishop E7 for some reason this
move Bishop F6 I still it's a very good
move by the way but for some reason it's
not the first move on my playlist it's
like I'm giving I'm giving up a bishop
for free that doesn't come naturally or
easily but then when you think about
this position logically Knight on F6 was
the best defender that black had truth
the change in it makes a lot of sense
and also the jump Knight E4 is
completely stopped and what's left on
the board is this bishop which
gets hit with a nice with a nice tempo
waiting to hit Bishop E7 on the board
now the question is she took immediately
wow she didn't even hesitate Ellen knows
this position I've got a feeling that
this is something
the preps this exact position because if
we look at her time she is down to 30
minutes right she knows the idea is in
the position right so yeah I think her
attack might just work up
it takes F6 you just need to maybe uh
speed up a little bit to explain this
position in time trouble right will not
be easy so I remember at the Baku
Olympiad I was watching uh Katya uh
Katarina themsova she won a very very
nice attacking game on the white side of
an advanced Caro where she got into time
trouble and everything
and I congratulated her and I said wow
that was a really great attacking game
and she said yeah Robert Hess
had prepared her incredibly well and she
was very very confident I said well if
it was all preparation why did you play
so slow and give your poor suffering
team captain a heart attack I was just
checking the lines I was just checking
the lines do you think that's what
Bella's doing because look at her she's
just played Bishop F6 and H4 a la tempo
as zif to say I have prepped this could
be and also could be that like I said
she knows the ideas but maybe she was
trying to remember the exact move order
right when to play A4 when to sacrifice
the pawn on A5 and so exactly this A4 A5
this Pawn sacrifice very very
interesting distraction I want to say to
bring the Knight over to A5 is the
Oracle warming up to White's position uh
I actually had another Harry Potter this
could Bella be Lauren her opponent you
know she
uh Irina has this position on the board
and I think her classical education does
not allow her to believe that she can be
much worse in this position but now here
comes the realization I think after
Bishop F6 Bishop F6 and H4 I wanted to
show you first of all what could be the
best option for black here because there
are way too many pieces looking at
Black's Kings here so you probably have
to exchange at least one of those and
deflect the bishop on C2 from
uh well the attack and then try play A5
Bishop C2 Bishop A6 and to activate your
poor Bishop on B7 but even here white is
slightly better and I think their
perspectives are
um how do you say ferric
well they will play this position maybe
they fly in colors they think but let's
say if you do something simple in well
H4 was played you will Retreat your
Bishop yeah it's a very natural reaction
prove your attack this move is very
dangerous Knight G5 not even G5 because
what are you supposed to do here if you
play H6
I will go Knight H7 oh my so rookie
eight and I will continue
uh my attack so I will play G5 or even I
well this was my human but the computer
says even
Knight F3 first so I will not allow E5
and then continue so I will deprive you
of any possible counter play and then
good so this looks very dangerous wow
but if you play G6 here oh then he says
wait don't rush no H5 but first
F4 protect the Knight and a lot of
sacrifices are possible then Knight H7
is maybe possible with F4 allows me to
play Queen H2 on the next move I will be
really worried if I would be Arena here
this looks like a very very dangerous
initiative I completely agree with you
uh yeah Arena has to be very careful at
this crucial Moment by the way again
just before we jump to our break I want
to check in on the game of harika for a
moment this game is kind of getting away
from us because the players have played
very slowly but even though the players
have played very slowly they've also
played those very very key moves after
we move Rook takes B7 we did see the
move Queen takes A4 not the Knight B6 or
anything and guess what
three F three just uh cementing the pawn
on e4 and the idea is Bishop to D E3
Rook B8 challenging The Rook something I
really like get rid of what's your best
piece The Rook on B7 let's trade it off
after F3 Rook B8 Bishop B3 on the board
Queen A5 Bishop D2 players are beginning
to speed up uh the tempo of the play but
it's still
um
well uh I want to say Triple H the one
the one I caught myself I thought that
you don't want to play Queen A3 here
because in my mind's eye I had seen
Bishop before trapping the queen until I
noticed Queen takes B3 and I decided a
break was in order that was like a
perfect time to have a break and as we
go on break we want to share with you uh
here in Missouri this uh celebrating the
bicentennial the 200 year anniversary of
Missouri State and Dr Jeannie sinkfield
and the Eagle Scouts had a very special
project have a look
in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parsons approved the building of a
life-size chessboard to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a lifelong
patron of scouting in Great Rivers
Council board member proposed that the
project be built as an Eagle Scout
project Jeannie invited 16 year old
Andrew Dowden of troop 6 Jefferson City
to take on this incredibly important
project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chessboard
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite I
wasn't very familiar with the technology
needed to engrave on there so I needed
some assistance with that and learning
how to do it and after all that I'm
pretty sure I know how to do it now so
to engrave those Edge pieces I went down
to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we used the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
it ended out to be a really really cool
project so we had a ribbon cutting of
the chess board and there were a whole
bunch of people there including the
governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project Jeannie was
there I had to give a little speech that
I didn't really know I had to do but
that kind has taught me a little bit
about speaking too so I think that has
helped me too this project it's made me
real proud that everyone is enjoying it
like every time I go down there
somebody's playing
um and then they're taking care of it
which really makes me proud because me
thinking all that time and everyone else
that's helped me sinking in all that
time like to see people use it but I
also like to see people appreciate it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our results so far we have one game
that finished in a drop between
Elizabeth pets and Jean Saya Abdul Malik
exactly maybe harika might be drawing as
well but the action let's jump right
into it there's got to be a uh the game
between Bella and Arena as uh I wanted
look how Irina sitting at her chair on
her chair oh with the with her feet
underneath right she knows that uh
there's a big fight on her board yeah
big attack is coming her way well when
we left it we mentioned uh a very
gosh cunning Sly move this bishop takes
F6 boy it's not intuitive because you
don't usually just voluntarily give up
your Bishop but check out what Bella had
in mind H4 starting an attack Knight to
G5 uh gift me the pawn on
H6 yes you're welcome to play G6 but as
almero showed after G6 F4 defending the
Knight ideas of Knight takes H7 as well
as H4 and H5 really come to the fore and
you don't want to play G6 you want to
chase the Knight back so you play H6
Knight doesn't go back the night jump
forward ahead
Knight to H7 and Arena stopping I think
I didn't expect it Knight H7
um half yes and maybe half said please
don't play Knight H7 like maybe she
expected but hoped her opponent wouldn't
uh play it now the problem is is that if
we move our Rook which well I mean it is
hanging oh she's thinking about it so
maybe she's considering to sacrifice
absolutely that's what I was thinking
she's thinking uh the move G5 and okay
you can just start you know just count
the number of pieces that are about to
uh land on the king side something tells
me you don't want to play G6 and allow
H5 this is uh this is really really
really Fierce attack now what you had
said caught my eye as well which is you
know maybe you should just sacrifice The
Exchange please do me a favor take the
rook and uh let me get coupons for the
exchange and my Kink and wrong I'm
afraid she's not going to take the Rook
afraid that she would just play Knight
F3 and the bishop comes back and once
again this move G5 so don't take the
pawn Maybe
maybe bail out and just Knight B3 or
maybe three I like you like might be yes
because I want to uh trade trade and
also like distract some of the white
pieces from the attack on the king side
okay that's fair that's fair and because
you're attacking my Rook I have to
respond so Knight takes B3 C takes B3
Bishop to D3 maintaining
of the defense if you will of the night
now rookie let's try it okay now okay
rookie eight but here I go G5 all I'm
trying to do obviously is just open up
uh direct lines you know I thought you
were going to say all I'm trying to do
is Checkmate yeah Matt too I mean easy
peasy uh I once asked
um Gary Kasparov a question when does an
attack begin
when does an attack begin
how did he answer I'm very curious to
hear yeah exactly me too I was very
curious to hear he said yes sir an
attack begins
when the Pawns
open up the position very good yeah and
it's such a simple answer but it's so
accurate sorry when the ponds open up
the position so Gary uh Gary Gary knew a
thing or two about an attack Almera take
it away how challenging is this attack
for arena
uh extremely yes so let me show you a
small variation which you considered
here Knight B3 and I think it will be
um it is important not to exchange
anything and to play Rook D1 and if you
take the Knight on D2 I can even take
with the Kindle look how safe yes
the White's position is so now I've
connected my Rooks and I think that the
attack is going to be unstoppable here
wow so Irina played rookie eight here
but her position is still uh very
dangerous so after rookie eight
let me see rookie I think that's the
move that I suggested earlier first of
all of course you're not threatening to
take on H4 but that might be a
possibility and you should always
deprive lack of any counter plane once
again this is a very unpleasant physical
feeling you're under attack there's
absolutely nothing that you can do you
have this bishop on B7 uh Knight on A5
sometimes like I I even feel that I
suffocate because there is nothing I can
do so how to stop this attack computer
is becoming desperate here He suggests
moves like E5 but after Knight E5 you
know there is absolutely nothing that
you can do you you will try to activate
your bishop and play Bishop D6 but then
F4 once again and my knight will wait
until the forces will come and help him
to attack so G5 will come up let's say I
will make a move I don't know just a
usual unnecessary move G5 and then
Knight F6 welcome
and the black's position is going to be
destroyed unfortunately absolutely
Mirabella actually made a move so
instead of Knight F3 she played G5 she
played G5 immediately very good for her
or well uh I don't know why a computer
considers it to be the second best in
this position she still keeps her
Advantage but after G5 now I understand
I think that after E5 here for example
if black tries to free himself in this
position so if you take only five there
might be some possibility to win
everything with Rook on H1 Bishop also
in D3 so you cannot take on the five so
maybe this way because this is the only
way for black to free himself in this
position so I think that that's why he
proposes a knight F3 first but let's
have a look uh E5 maybe Queen H5
and this looks devastating once again so
maybe even this is winning for white so
I'm not sure
could you give an advice yes sir yeah
well I I I'm looking from Bella's point
of view and I'd like what I'm seeing I
like the move G5 I like E5 by the way E5
you know me take the pawn
take the pawn go ahead Munch D4 yeah go
go ahead Rook G1
D3 go ahead
Queen H5
and I was like like it's G6 Check Yes
you had to go back I was taking on F7
and this as far as I got and I was
thinking
oh
I don't know maybe you can still go Rook
G6 but they will have Bishop Buffet no I
will oh Rook G6 Bishop oh no I was
thinking I was mating
it looks like white should be made I
know I was so close oh no but why not
Queen H5 I don't know I I was beginning
hyper aggressive E4 yeah that's the idea
of course once again the white will
never take only five and that's very
deep because you need to play E4 and to
close the bishop on C2 and you no longer
have this possibility to bring your
knight into play but computer what does
it say gitex H6 just open up the
position it's G6 once again and now ah
you have this very nice move Queen A5 so
you cannot take the the Knight of course
because you are mated it's a very
important tactical motive here so after
Queen F5 what do you do F6 then Queenie
six once again you cannot take this
Knight the Knight is leading a Charmed
Life it's an uncapturable touchable yes
yes so you have to play King h8 here and
now you are simply H5 I think that's yes
this is
um painful it wasn't queen of seven also
Queen F7 yeah yeah the queen so somehow
this Knight is leading uh very very
charm light let's go around the the
playing Hall and see uh the other games
I want to jump to the game with
Alexandra and uh Anna zatonski
Anna as we know is in her habitual uh
time
serious time trouble now because it's
serious already we've only seen 15 moves
so there's 25 moves to go before the
time control and she only has 12 minutes
left exactly however Alexander doesn't
have much much time either and the
position is really rich very intriguing
I I actually like Anna's position we
left it at these this point and this
moment there was a very nice and hidden
hidden uh threat we we were primarily
concentrating on King G1 a very strange
shuffling little move why because if we
play a move a desirable move like H4 in
order to develop The Rook let's move
Bishop C2 Queen takes C2 is a nasty
discovered check tactic picking up the
queen so Alexander saw that but she
didn't want to play the move King G1 she
played instead excuse me she played
instead Queen C3 sidestepping and as we
were on break you know where Caro
conquer so you know we we we're we're
natural we were thought we were thinking
you know it'd be kind of fun to put the
bishop on e4 even at the cost of a pawn
and uh this light squared Bishop would
actually dominate the action instead on
an understandably developed to pieces
and she's just played the move Rook C8
with 12 minutes on her clock
double-edged game but I like her
position Flex position is fantastic it's
just that time trouble can really play a
huge role here in this game yeah
Grandma's Maurice Ashley says his best
uh time travel makes fools of all of us
yes exactly and uh inviting Queen takes
B7 but I like what's going on 20 what
how many movies 25 moves to go
time management come on so she asked
about uh
she's gonna have to really yeah really
uh speed it up uh and Erika and gunay uh
this game well how to put it we almost
suspected at a certain moment that there
was going to be a repetition like the
the queen was dancing around the board
and we got to this position and Erika
said you know what
let's let's play for the win let's let's
go Rook takes Rook takes Queen check and
actually I think gunny rejected the
repetition she did uh Bishop E3 she
could have gone Queen A3 back and then
repetition would have happened but she
played Queen C3
and the difference being that if I play
Bishop to D2
[Laughter]
oh
discovered attack
nasty discovered attack look at that
hello tried too hard to avoid Perpetual
exactly that so I was thinking Bishop D2
was still the repetition but okay it
didn't happen we're we're catching up
with the players
D2 no um quindy for check
and I was gonna go Bishop to E3 maybe I
can take one D1 and go two Rooks against
ah two Rooks against the queen in this
position you know I can yeah two Rooks
is is much much much uh better chances
than the rook and the bishop okay uh
current position tell us about it how do
you feel about the current position
any problems for black sub
the knights are blockade in d61 so well
and if black starts to push the a pawn I
would be worried with white exactly uh
the two Bishops I love the bishop on B3
in terms of its aggression towards the
king the bishop on E3 looks good but
then how pertinent is it as you said the
knights defending blockading very well
is time a factor in these games uh not
really so harika has 16 minutes and
gunai has 35. Queen D1 by harika
inviting the trade of Queens let's let's
take a look at them apples because that
is an ending where well black is a pawn
up after all and here I think white has
Bishop A4 okay
Bishop A4 I want to move this C Pawn
because I don't like it on C6 uh just
asking the question check King F2 check
King
yeah that was the question I was asking
like were you maybe I can play Rook D2
okay
good game we'll be
happy sues to win the A5 pawn and be
happy
[Music]
okay you you made a decent point there
for sure I probably in that case uh
instead of giving the second check maybe
you play C5
um
I what can I say there was a game
yesterday
that was absolutely absolutely
confounding Bella sacrificed upon and
she was better literally the whole game
upon down here I'm in an end game I'm a
pawn up as black I think I'm happy
happyish
sure why not I'll be happyish uh this
ending help us out uh Almera how does
the Oracle evaluate the current game
position after Queen D1
or just a second that this position is
absolutely equal
so what says the Oracle yes zeros across
yes you can have a look but I think that
yes uh White's pair of Bishop and
general pieces activity compensates yes
for the Palm like for the extra pound
that black has and um
I think that
well it's rather balanced but I wanted
to draw your attention to the game
between uh hampi Canary and Nana
jugnizzi because we we haven't analyzed
it for a while because it was rather a
rather calm position but I think that
grumpy missed a very very interesting uh
possibility to gain an advantage so
let's have a look at this ghee because
okay now I think it's more or less
sequel but here after Knight D7 she
could have played F5
simply leaving The Rook on E5 and I
think that after
95 GTX E5 Queen C7 F6
King H7 a very nice move Bishop G2
because you want to play F4 in the next
move and black species are very very
passive and the King
is quite weak here so I tried something
very human Rook cd8 here and then H4
let's say D4 I don't know I didn't know
how to improve so after Queen A4 like
white is already winning
even being an exchange down so wow that
was a very very nice possibility for
hampi to claim the advantage let's say
what if you don't take this Rook on E5
you play I tried the once again a very
human move book of Fate okay try
something so H4 simply H4 please take my
row yes you can take you the Rook any
time I will increase the pressure let's
say Rook cd8 you don't have any move
because I am controlling the E file
right so black is condemned to a passive
play so they have to wait and now I can
improve my my Rooks position I can even
play rookie 7 then improve any of my
pieces and because you can no longer
play Knight F6 I will play G5
so um I think that was a missed
opportunity to win the game yeah an
extraordinary positional uh exchange
sacrifice wow nice nice find there a
Charming in fact I wanted to draw our
attention to our other our tournament
leaders are having a having trouble
Arena today is under uh well seriously
yes and uh well
yeah Anna has a nice position I want to
say so she's got this French
position as uh black where her two minor
pieces specifically the night on C4 and
the bishop on A4 occupying really key
um
outposts yes and then after this move
Rook just defending the night just
saying hey I'm ready to play H6 I'm
ready to play Knight F5 what are you
doing you're what are you doing Bishop
D1 Bishop takes D1 Rook takes D1 on
has got a great position
upon at least upon oh the magic words uh
Queen A6 setting up uh discover checks
Galore against the king as you say she's
getting ready to win upon maybe she's
this bishop dark swear Bishop doesn't
really have a future the exposition is
absolutely
it's a dream position I know I know the
clocks are a factor but for for
Alexandra she is not a happy camper even
though her opponent only has 10 minutes
position definitely favors yeah she only
has 10 minutes but now position is a lot
more simplified and it's much easier for
black to play exactly not only she's
going to pick up a pawn but next couple
of moves just very easy yes Tempo tempos
uh so this one's looking very very good
for Anna let's just check in with Arena
one more time because when we left the
ballot just you know is throwing the
kitchen sink against Arena's King Knight
A7 she did
throwing kitchens exactly there is uh
yeah that that's literally throwing
everything you know the dishes the pans
even the sink you throw it through the
sink I love that line that Almera
suggested Rook D1 Knight takes D2 King
takes D2 something very beautiful
Harmony uh going on there uh I can't
fault Bella one bit by the way for
capturing and putting a bishop on D3
either uh this position
you know the night you know is saying
hey guys rescue me you know rescue me
and where and white is saying don't
worry don't worry we're coming we're
coming and queen H5 or queen G4 all this
moves G5 takes H6 these moves are coming
and arena is Arenas clocking issue uh
Irina has a little bit more time than
Bella she has 23 minutes okay spell us
16 minutes more even I would say uh
between them yes uh just like for Anna
it's pretty easy to play for Bella I
think just yes throw the pieces yeah
you're a student body right just bring
everybody to the party over there this
block have to push the panic button here
and just go E5 and try to
something uh yeah I I can well imagine
that but sometimes you know you you
accelerate your own demise when you're
fighting back from a position of
inferiority I don't see how Irina could
passively defend and save this game so
exactly well we'll take a look at E5 and
I just want to once again say that in
their head-to-head clashes I was a
little bit surprised that Bella had a
pretty it had a plus score I mean
because I've always thought of Arena
especially against International
competitors is doing very well but this
is this was a surprise for me at three
to two with two draws but I like your
move E5 you got to do something crazy
let's go she played it anyway and just
played E5 because
if you don't do anything I mean if if
you if you play uh dead guess what
you're going to be killed very very
quickly very very quickly and queen H5 G
takes so I mean you might say born of
desperation but required okay
you can also take on age six
let's have a look this is this is the
chaos well if it is chaos this is what I
think arena is hoping that she'll be
able to do is uh cause white to at least
stop right is it
is it uh what is it is it winning or
losing right what is it Queen G4 a G6 H5
this doesn't look like it's necessarily
it's fine here
[Applause]
so I was thinking okay instead of G5
takes H6 you cause me to stop and to
take D4 okay and of course I I see
you're you're ambushing my Rook but now
I want to bring my uh crook into the
game the take on C3 all right let's go
you I I feel like you're mauling me on
the uh Center and the queen side B2 oh
dear
oh dear okay
hand hand over my heart I know my neck
smoke
okay well pause uh but
I I always liked this line of Victor
Cortana we're Trembling Hands uh rippity
one uh I don't know if Knight F6 or
Knight G5 is which of those two but for
the moment it's it's kind of funny to
see these pawns so let's do Bishop
before check okay well F1 and queen
takes H4
roro
you've got uh some counter Spiel going
on over here
that might be blundering made in three
but
well do tell if you see a maiden three
let me let me know uh
holy smokes Eve
E4 H6 is happening F3 or E4 looks yeah I
didn't want to block the bishop so I was
looking at F3 yeah mostly right to to
keep the maybe here I can just be brave
and take on H6 wow
uh we're just looking at some variations
we're just having a little fun with the
uh position uh between Arena and Bella
um but jump in on this one Almira it
feels like white is killing it but she
has to be precise
uh first of all of course Rook D1 was a
more precise move here as we've analyzed
previously but it is what it is now so D
takes E5 now is called four of course D4
is the black's idea G1 yeah did you take
C3 right and I think that well in the
line that you analyzed let's say G takes
H6
she takes B2 it's very important not to
take on G7 not to take yes because how
could I resist
but I knew my opponent she was playing
me like a Biddle
I tried to understand why a little bit
later but I think there is a very
important tactical resource Knight F6
that you need to keep under your sleeve
I think so here you have to play uh Rook
D1 okay and you keep all the threads on
the board so uh you I don't think that
you can play uh Queen D5 here so you try
the reserve move Bishop B4 so King F1
and you see that now Queen when you play
Queen H4 I do have this Knight of six
yes and so that's more effective where
you go I will take on G7 so I think uh
King h8 is simply not possible so King
f8 then I will take on G7 the position
is extremely Sharp but black has to find
the only moves so King E7 here
here I didn't know what to choose from a
human perspective because you have so
many moves I don't want to play Queen G4
I was not sure that if you can trade
Queens you will win this game but the
computer suggested another move that He
suggests is F3
which is a bit strange to me but so I
let's try Queen G4 here so Queen G4 Rook
G4 and the thing is so even though you
uh traded Queens you have this very
important threat of well playing G8 on
the next move and you are completely
winning so
I tried another line here
so after D4 Rook G1
G takes C3 this is the move that
computer does not propose no this is not
his first two lines but once again from
a human perspective I want to play
native six here exactly maybe this is
also possible so and after King h8 he
thinks that this is equal but the line
is very complicated let's say after 98
you do not take this Rook back but you
play Bishop before wow this is way too
complicated I think for a human mind or
at least you need more time to figure
out everything so Queen E8 then Queen G4
so of you see she takes B2 the line
continues Rook D1 Bishop f8 like how in
this crazy position evaluation is just
zeros
right we need five and the game
continues actually it's still a game
anything is possible uh remarkable stuff
thank you for that Amira and
um in our discussion as to what to name
the chess engine
we had a viewer's poll and it comes
Yasser wants to name the yes yes it does
want the name the Oracle the Oracle of
St Louis do you agree do you have
another Choice 73 that's what I'm saying
you know thank you thank you audience
loves you there oh you think that's
right yeah you think that it's a
Prejudice yes well 26 disagreed how dare
they I know like shame or I think
Almira was one of them
uh by the way uh brought to you by
Sabina fuser and Sabina on our break she
was telling how excited she was she was
getting interviews with inside and
Elizabeth together yeah together and uh
we don't get that you have to go to the
social media to see what videos is
producing she's going to post it if she
hasn't already on San Luis uh chess club
Instagram account right now since we're
getting crazy uh I just wanted to ask a
little bit crazy takes on E5 D4 which we
have on the board by the way do we do
also on the board taking on C3
uh I did tell you I was an agent
provocateur right like I do like
provoking my opponents is it completely
insane what I'm about to propose which
is to Castle long
no I like it
if it's it's either completely insane
yeah it's completely fine thank you
and the answer is the envelope will open
up the envelope what the heck I'm
castling but I'm trying to connect my
Rooks I'm trying to play that human move
Knight F6 and I want to
you're kind of creating Checkmate uh
around your King right instead of taking
on B2 I like C2 more ah C2 because if
you take with the bishop my C files open
and I would love to have counter attack
on the C file and I just walked into a
loss of a piece if you don't take it
then
I just need to get my queen on A5 yeah
A4 yeah Queen A4 uh a little bit crazy I
I I have to admit that uh I I was being
my provocative best but I was hoping uh
that you would let me hide if you will
behind this Pawn structure it looks good
here it's funny because blood can just
go A5 a43
you know I love a chess variant called
horde that's where all the piece black
gets all pawn pardon me white gets all
pawns black gets all pieces and you and
you go crazy with your H wow okay uh
great stuff Uh current position uh arena
is facing Rook G1 this she doesn't
really have a choice right she has to
take on uh C3 and clocks are beginning
this is this is very very tense first
place is up for grabs for arena
she did it as Alexandra's looking like
she might go down today exactly what
just happened to our tournament leaders
here we go she's taken on C3 key moment
right here it is absolutely critical
moment and we were looking at GTX H6 but
I think there's so many other options
here for example immediately Knight F6
and just taking on E8 looks good well
that was the one that Amira was saying
that uh oh she takes on H6 I love how
they're blitzing right I mean these um
these extremely difficult decisions
they're making them as if they're
they're the most natural moves in the
world at least Bella's playing Just
intuitively
because there's so much to calculate and
you could spend 13 minutes or three
hours here and still not be sure what
you should play you should just go in
and play in what intuitively she feels
is the right thing to do and this is the
moment I believe where Bishop B4 as
opposed to Queen takes E8 was the
suggestion of the the Oracle uh Bishop
B4 uh so night so no nighting
do this again no Knight F6 check but
rather G5 takes and this is the crazy
stuff that went takes right we looked at
City xb2 yes and now the whole point is
not to play Rook takes G7 to keep that
move in it would be so hard to believe
yourself from playing rookies I feel
like Dr Strangelove and I'd be fighting
myself you know like the hand wants to
take the pawn on G7 can't do it where's
Peter Sellers when you need him look to
D1 instead she takes B2 clue black just
take 9
only okay let's blast I'm also walking
away from Knight F6 so let's blast
H5 blasting away okay and
let's take on B2 now
wow you have to have ice water in your
veins to look at your king okay Rook to
D1 and same line let's say Bishop before
check oh the same stuff I'm getting
kicked to F1 and you've got to set up
counter threats
okay check I guess there's now a knight
F6 I can go King hate my Palms are not
hanging on G7 anymore exactly there's no
that's interesting there's no G
yeah so maybe Knight F6 is not good I
don't need it I don't well excuse me
either but here I'm back to those
variations where I'm playing either F3
or queen G4 or yeah well Queen G4 is a
weird one right
there's a bishop hanging on H on Pardon
Me there's a bishop hanging on B4
I'm happy to trade the Queens but at the
same time I might still lose some I
don't know it's it's a it's a crazy
variation right takes check King h a
takes you've got Bishops F3 a lot of
extra pawns right well yeah and they're
scary pawns too Bishop F3 Rook takes
Bishop takes
I mean look at what's going on here
you're threatening Bishop
uh my mind is spinning my brain hurts uh
this is but I think this is crazy stuff
Almira and Oracle have yes and that's
some suggestions uh as to how we might
improve our play uh great stuff G takes
H6 on the board what did we miss Almira
uh yes
she's gonna write a book
yes let's say G6 first yeah there is a
very powerful move here which you missed
is E6 nice oh
incredible a second move I like it let's
have a look first of all if you take on
B2 now it can take maybe G7 that's
simple and of course black is completely
lost so Bishop D5 is a very nice
defensive idea but here I was also torn
and I think there is Rook G6 what can
you do here for example if you take F
take G6 green G4 wins immediately so
when you play Rook G6 you have to play
King h8 in order to stay alive here so
then natural you'll take an F7 wait
sorry and actually black is only
slightly worse after taking on F7 and
Bishop F7 what as you would imagine
what I would not imagine that black is
only slightly worse but here after
Bishop D5
I think that now you can play H5 so then
you will be able to take on G6
yeah I know that E6 move is it it's so
much Superior because first of all
you're putting your Pawn to use and
you're really making Black's whole
structure that much looser but the move
E6 oh
right it's also the line that we're
looking at instead of E6
um
yeah which is probably a bad move E6 is
better much better uh could could we
once again go back to this takes on B2
business oh before okay so let's take on
bitcoin
she just played it too because
if Rook takes G7 check as a trap right
for your opponent well let's invite our
opponent to make a bad move and Rook
takes G7 check is so compelling I I mean
you have to be
the patience of the Sphinx
Rook takes G7 okay Rook D1 yep G6 I
think is probably necessary yes but then
your E6 move right does that come back
into the maybe Knight G5 first of all
Knight G5 Knight G5 here you can come
back wow
that's so simple
and of course now you can play H5 and
I'm I cannot see how you can defend this
position
maybe at some point you will be able to
play B1 Queen to deflect the bishop but
I think then but our Mary helped me out
so Knight comes to G5 if I go Bishop B
for check the king would have to go to
F1 right
now the crazy part is I don't think I'm
worried about losing my queen like Rook
takes Bishop take oh oh I'm recognizing
this is I think that you can take on B2
first ah of course taking on B2 it's not
that obvious because of course you will
have Queen F6 and then computer
continues you can take on G6 but you can
play H5 here so you cannot take Rook G5
because you're Queen yes
wow I I've got a feeling that we could
get completely absorbed lost in the
entanglements of what's going on here I
just wanted to ask how Anna zatonski and
uh she's still much much better is she
really and they're in the end game yes
and they're in the end game I have one
more question for you of course it takes
B2 if Bella doesn't play Rook D1
uh is she losing G7 or any other move
first I wanted to tell you because we
haven't looked at the evaluation of the
position between Anna and Alexandra and
this is actually surprising because I
didn't understand what Alexandra was
doing at all and the computer confirms
my intuition the evaluation right now is
-3.2 wow so this end game is completely
winning for this like middle game end
game is completely winning for black
okay very extra Pawn yes an extra pound
once again there is absolutely no plan
for white whatsoever no active plan and
the night can come to F5 I think that if
Anna doesn't spoil this game in the time
travel she is heading for another
Victory she's about to take down the
leader
I know well first of all that would
boost her fortunes put her potentially
into this tournament she was the last
suit by reading absolutely she's having
a fantastic tournament absolutely uh so
this is the yeah but three and a half
minutes on the clock this is where you
you see your nerves if it was anyone
else I would say oh they're in time
trouble they can mess up but it's Anna
she's after this
well there's something about being
practiced right I mean
I get nervous when I'm I I'm in time
trouble because it's an unusual feeling
to be in time trouble for me uh for Anna
is probably the most familiar film thing
and so she's she's perfectly at home
um but there was a question that Nasi
had for you
um Ameren that was uh if
Bella is seduced by the idea of Rook
takes G7 check
would the position be significantly
worse for her or after King age eight
how does the Oracle evaluate Rook takes
G7
and King AJ the position like divorce
minus seven
minus seven yes the evaluation changes
dramatically yes because we miss
something then no it's that was the line
that you actually analyzed and then
after Bishop before King F1 Queen H4 is
a very powerful move and here you will
have to deal with all the threats from
the black side exactly what what did you
analyze here
sorry I misunderstood you when you said
minus seven I thought you for for why
like that like the position was uh and
Bella
yeah yeah uh Rook takes G7 sure looks
attractive but Rook D1 was the game
continuation and again uh both ladies
their clocks are ticking and they're
making some really difficult decisions
quickly and this was the right one Rook
to D1 check and again G6 or Bishop B4
check what would you find yourself I
would be tempted to give a check right
yeah for for
let me explain why I would also be
attempted to give the check because I'm
thinking that the queen on d8 has got to
go has got to go can't stay in the way
of the rook and when I'm playing Queen
takes H4 I'm getting out of the way and
at the same time I'm having my counter
attacks here is is the the line Almera
had proposed some time ago where you
know you hope you know you're not going
to get a rook D7 check and a Splat right
you hope it's not roadkill uh
but for arena what G7 that's just
fireworks on the board yeah exactly but
G6 Bishop check and G6 is something I
would think I I'm losing I'm losing it's
too slow I can't get away with it
Almera from a human point of view
um would you
play G6 or Bishop B4 check for getting
the computer for just a second of course
first of all I think that from my human
point of view you need to understand if
you need to include Bishop before and
then play G6 and I think that when you
play G6 you consider that the moves E6
are possible that's why you include the
move Bishop B4 it's not so much for
taking on H4 but I think that uh well
when you see a six you think oh my God I
will have to deal with another threat
which
uh so could be devastating potentially
so we'll play Bishop B4 first and then
G6 right but this position reminds me of
a story when I was which way I was
reading when I was a kid and at some
point the warrior was facing a difficult
choice and it was written carved in the
stone so on the right if you shall go in
the right then you you'll lose your
horse okay what to do on the left then
you're going to lose your life so
and and if you go straight then there is
your face in the unknown so well
everything is said in the story right
for me I'm not willing to sacrifice my
horse let's go with the unknown on this
one
um we're going to take a very quick
break as our tournament leaders are in
great Peril and we will see you on the
other side of the break
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varuja nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 200 150 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
hello everyone this is wgm a former U.S
women's champion Sabina fosher I'm very
excited to be here in San Luis at the
Third Edition of the Karen's cup I'll be
taking over San Luis chess club social
media accounts so please if you want to
interact with me and see more behind the
scenes
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our results so far we've had two
draws between Elizabeth Pals and Johnson
abdumalik and the second draw drona
Valley and Mama Zetta yeah harika did
make that repetition in the ending and a
draw but the big news is our two
tournament leaders Arena crush and
Alexandra are both in uh well troubles
but this last move Queen takes B2 uh
that Bella played
um
that move that it it does that allow
Arena to fight back that was the
question because we didn't see the
bishop before jet we saw G7 G6 I think
this is where Amira was suggesting
Knight G5 which is a move I'd want to
resist I mean I couldn't really find
myself playing a move like that I could
imagine myself playing E6 you know those
types of moves but uh she did play Queen
takes B2 and she has in mind E6 what's
gonna happen here and Nasi what's your
what's your thought can she take on H7
or she can also give Bishop before check
here and then take on H7
should be for check I guess I'm going to
play King E2 take on
and and we have E6 E6 is what I I want
to do and Bishop takes G6 check is my
backup plan uh not easy to play right
and very hard to calculate and what did
Irina took on H7 without giving a check
Queen takes oh yes right because now on
E6 black just has Bishop F6
uh sorry King so she took immediately by
the way their clock ring us down to one
minute oh my and she still has 13 moves
to make Queen takes B2 King no Bishop
check sorry let me just uh clarify that
she took immediately and the idea she's
ready to meet E6 with Bishop F6 not only
protecting
um G7 but
countering with uh this maybe can we
continue
here yeah I was going to play Queen B3
without E6 because that looked very
interesting oh it's right here right
here
okay because again I've got I've got
checks and if nothing else I have two
pawns for the bishop I sacrificed
Fortnight yeah
okay Bishop to D5 can I can I resist
hoping I could go Bishop G6 here okay
and can I resist takes five
oh dear the attack's not over it sure
just beginning Bishop B4 check taking E2
I'm doing my best I'm gonna I mean I
feel like I I feel like I bought it the
the the edge of a cliff and I I'm
sliding off of it and she takes the pawn
on B3 very attractive move Queen takes
B3 Jump Right In uh I'll mirror what
what is what's happening first of all
the evaluation has changed here after
the move G6 uh the first line of course
is Knight G5 and white is winning so
plus two the second line is Queen B2 the
move that Bella played like this move
doesn't yield white any advantage so for
the moment it's equal while even though
the position is still very complicated
but King H7 is a very good move here so
Queen B3 I just wanted to show you uh
what happens if I take the queen
immediately so right uh Bishop G6 if
they G6 so I'll take on Z8 rook's d8 so
I can take on B3 now and actually here
there is a very important resource I'll
play Bishop before check I'll deflect
your queen from the F7 Square so Queen
before and now Bishop F3 so you threaten
the mate on D1 there's not much that you
can do you have to defend it by the way
sorry to just uh interrupt you but uh
Arena display to move down with 10
seconds to play and the following the
line that Nasi and I were looking at
Bishop D5 if uh just noticed besides
Bishop G6 Bella also has Bishop C4 is
that just winning the piece back Bishop
C4 so the idea is this should take C4
Queen takes C4 massive threat of mate in
a few and so I still have yeah you're
winning the piece back but is it
completely winning after division before
Jack so this is my bailout variation I
don't know uh can I resist like this
with queenies yeah Bella wouldn't want
to simplify since Irina has 36 seconds
exactly Bishop D5 on the board with 36
seconds and Arena
getting very nervous I I see her in her
seat uh rocking but you said she's got
her feet underneath her yes yes she does
that I mean I've played her so many
times I know whenever she is in time
trouble or nervous yeah
yeah so Bishop D5 uh
well Jump Right In
um amera Bishop D5 the current
evaluation after this move uh just a
second because I was trying to analyze
Bishop G6 so after Bishop C4 the
computer thinks that white is a slightly
better but that's the variation that
you've seen on the board so you take to
C4
yes Bishop before I mean before he
thinks that Queen is seven is uh is a
slight in accuracy here maybe Queen C7
is a bit better here because after Queen
is seven
Queen F4 and you cannot take on E5 with
your Rook that's why Queen C7 is
more precise and because you can see
slightly better the attack continues but
after H5 black will take on E5 and I
think yes wow okay uh just uh to
interrupt you once again sorry for that
but uh the amazingly Anna she repeated
much just to gain time she she repeat
it's a move just for the clock uh Bishop
D6 Rook da bishop and Anna who look
let's let's she knows closer to move
forward exactly that's what it's all
about is just getting in those extra
moves getting that 30 seconds on the
clock she's a completely winning
position Knight E4 M it's not just that
she's a pawn up but she's actually
blunting any types of attacks towards
her King in other words The Rook on G4
was hoping that its colleague would go
to G3 so you could double up the Rooks
and a good day you could plant Rook
takes G7 and say I've got counter play
not when the night's on e4 we have
another big update you know happy seems
to be winning now oh my not sure what
went wrong in Nana's position but
um the current position with Rook on E7
is black getting track made in a few
moves where does the king go well I
don't think you can take the Pawn King
takes G6 walks into horrible horrible uh
things with can I hide the king king H
King H6 quind D3 same idea of Rook D7
no no you're right yeah you have to try
King G8 maybe can I go King f8 okay
let's do it and here Queen E1 should be
good Queen oh nasty nasty Queen E1 I
also want to go Queen H1 as well if
somehow it defend E6
yeah this should be over okay so if I
defend E6
by by tickling The Rook
wow I'm sorry I I wanna leave this
exploding exactly all at the same time
Arena just made her move with seven
seconds to spare on a clock Bishop takes
G6
Rook takes D5 Queen C7 so how many pawns
do we have
I can't count two I think two well well
okay with both our tournament leaders
losing that opens up uh the possibility
for the player in third place
but Anna's playing one of the tournament
leaders so uh Arena loses Anna wins
she's first place who picked Anna to win
the tournament no one I'm ashamed of you
guys what's wrong okay sorry Queen C7 in
this position that's why I have Rook D7
what's up to seven
uh Bishop B4 check
I've got distribution
it's illegal that was my go-to move oh
no gosh I should take on E5
wait hold on can you quit Okay no Rook
D7 is I don't Queen takes E5 Queen F7
engage eight only move
uh
how can this not be made
um
uh calling Almira yes I have actually a
draw for you in this position a draw
anyone I don't want no stink and draw
sorry
move of course is quinnified Jack Queen
F7 King hates right Rook G6 sounds good
there is not much that you can do uh
what the giyanla is here I think Bishop
before Check Yes King F1 rookie seven
but that's the only way to defend from
the mate on H7 sorry so rookie seven
Queen is seven here a very nice smooth
geometrical motive Queen C4 so I'm
threatening uh yes Queen D4 so Queen C5
Queen five seconds
she did not oh first of all there was no
there was no Rook D7 there was an H5
sorry we got carried away by Rook D7 uh
Bella played H5 G5
G5 has just been Arena played with four
seconds on the clock and by the way
Queen check Rook D7 she can still play
Rook D7 now Rook D7 Queen takes E5
um hold on how how is this not
meaningful less than a minute oh my gosh
Bella's looking for a checkmate
Irina is trying to avoid checks e six
what's E6 wow
E6 what has to be slow
yeah oh for sure I I was so focused on
Rook D7 Queen D3 check
um Rook takes No rookie seven can black
just pick up the pawn on H6 King H6
or she goes Rook d8 Rook d8
Oh that's oh my gosh the time trouble is
oh my God Queen B1
queen queen B1 oh talk about geometry
wait is Queen D3 also winning yes
Queen D3 oh Bella found the Checkmate
exactly King
Queen B1 and queen A1 is style she's
missed has Arena king h8 queen D4 check
and Bella saw we call this the ladder
check yeah I heard when Bella played E6
far said that was a blunder and black
was winning up 36. no way yes I don't
know what is the right move to win well
I think your king it takes H6 was maybe
the the way the Queen the three
checkmates yeah she is missed Queen D3
check and Arena
is getting checkmated it's that simple
is it over let's say Bishop F6 in this
position oh sorry uh E6 the current d8
Queen D3 check
King
Queen D4 checks only move takes Bishop
takes uh Queen takes F6 check King H7
how can this not be
check mating and we have this on the
board
sure there is a meet
um it sure feels like it right even if
it's not me
Queen F5 check there's an
very
very nice way to finish the game is Rook
D7 check and then Queen G6 yes that that
that is the nicest way so she's played
Queen F5 check it doesn't disturb
anything but there is the very nice
aesthetically pleasing Rook D set and
then check and you get to pick up this
guy with a check uh but this one is also
very uh good
it doesn't change anything by the way
you have to go King h8 and I can play
the same idea as before Queen F6 check
and Rook D7 uh time uh sorry the the
number of moves we have five moves left
in control but I think game might be
over before that exactly so we think
arenas
lost we think Bella is going to win this
game I just want to check in with the
game of Anna because again time travel
in this game as well
yes but actually Alexandra has caught up
Rubble Shields also down three minutes
uh down to three minutes yeah
and Anna is plus six so she's got this
she only has three more moves to make
Before Time control only three more
moves so they're moves 37 an extra Pawn
fabulous pieces for black save King love
it sorry arena is also winning her game
right she did play Queen D7 and uh
yeah we were looking at some ideas where
Chief was Chief we're just playing no
pardon me okay six
um I'm not sure why because three so the
idea behind homie's F3 is very clear she
wants to play why didn't she play rookie
seven right away I think Almira is
saying the kind of blunder yeah it's a
huge blunder because from from uh okay
I'm just gonna tell me what it is after
she shouldn't have played F3 yeah the
move which changes the relation from
winning to equal rookie 7 was completely
winning because uh because well where do
you go Queen D6 but then they simply
play rookie eight check then yes rookie
eight I have to pay qg7 yes Queen f8
sorry trade you want me to do yes yes
yes I I yes you trade and then Queen f8
okay and then Queen D7 yep
and then this position is hopeless
because you have no moves with your
queen you're almost in stalemate wow so
in Suk Swang if you want but here like
Queen H6 is the only is the only move
but then Queen F7
Queen F6 and so on gotcha and in the
current position Nana now played D3 and
she has counter play
because it deep ones distracting White's
Queen on the Rooks so F3 D3 idea of D2
because the Rook is attached pardon me
the queen is
um
must protect the the
queen D Queen E3 sidestepping D2 maybe
ready to play King uh a mirror your your
hands are going in the air like
Mamma Mia what's going on minus 10 now
after this move Queen is three you know
no the tables have turned this is such a
dramatic turn of events because after
the three Queen three uh black is
actually winning because you will play
D4 okay so you can show it on the board
she didn't play it she didn't play it
she played quincy queen
C2 no but Queen City is also a very good
move because D4 was with the idea of
playing Queen seed on the next move so
it's fine and now there is not much that
you can do so
he's losing she went from she completely
winning to last with Queen E3 one yes
starting with f three inaccurate move
and then Queen E3 cd1 and now you play
D4 did she play King A1 no this is time
travel yeah time travel this is uh last
three moves before the time control she
has just completely well uh D3 upset her
but Queen CH she just didn't have that
on her radar kind look at the clock two
one she's lost on time
she lost on time right there's a
Checkmate in two moves Queen C2 Queen D1
and there she's done she resigned wow
Nana's lucky day today
whoa what an amazing oh my gosh what a
tournament an arena time trouble still
or what's going on uh yes they're on
move 39 but Bella is completely
overwhelming uh Black's King right she's
just well
[Laughter]
responsibility after this last uh
situation what were you gonna say
um maybe black can yes Queen C4 and for
some exchanges and then in The Rook end
game Bella does have extra pawns but
they're like H Double H ponzer what what
what I'm sure it's still winning just no
Checkmate I don't see a Checkmate oh no
we we're trading the pieces with the
check hold on the the game flares anew
because I thought
if you go King I was just going to make
you simple right yeah but here you have
Queen C1 check and I can't avoid
the trades the trades I'm gonna have to
play King F3 Queen takes D5 and that's
check and as we know Rook endings no
mate but she has to win this end game
well we saw her technique yesterday uh
will it uh
so the crazy thing is that Nana who is
almost lost
would have been in the eighth place if
she had lost him and now after her win
she's sharing first
be serious
hitting a trampoline just a second hold
on and this is where we saw humpy's flag
this move Queen C8 completely
discombobulated her and her clock ticks
down ticking ticking
fatal there it is she's reaching too
late I think
because it turned
30 minutes before
and they hadn't reached
hey good point we're asked Judith our
chief Arbiter to look into that because
how interesting was the 40th movement
she didn't click yet right so you
shouldn't have turned you shouldn't have
given her 30 minutes
interesting an equipment malfunction
let's get on it uh turning to Anna
zutanski and
Alexandra for just a moment a rich time
control
uh good good for Anna zutanski fans
Knight C6 Bishop A3 and oh this is just
great I mean it has no moves everything
has gone wrong offsides offsides you
know defensive defensive uh complete
domination here for Anna let's just jump
back to the arena game for a moment
um how did how did did she how did she
survive uh she is yes she is missed
um did uh Bella the decisive Rook D7
check and picking up so she went Queen
F5
and then she
repeated a few times just the rich moved
40. and so she could play Rook takes G5
and this is where they repeated a few
times they just reached them on 40 so
now she's gonna take her time and figure
out how to win this end game wow
um Amira jump in uh we have seen
so many of uh the competitors I don't
know how they do it
making a move with one second on their
clock and somehow completing the moves I
I'm not saying this is a first but it's
a rarity that we see players lose on
time
yes the one that comes to mind with the
evanchook once lost on time and I think
he in the candidates he lost five games
five five in one tournament
what yes exactly what indeed and this is
a replay of what we just saw as canero
she definitely flagged but the clock was
on her side right it was it was trying
to help there was a maiden too
nonetheless because there was Queen C2
check and queen D1 or made in three
and this is what our day looks like so
far conero just lost to nanotechnica
Crazy ending and two draws between pets
Abdul Malik and Toronto Valley Mama's
Adam I gotta tell you drills and Spills
that was a massive spill as Hobie uh
just let it Let It Go and here we have
poor Alexandra who came into today
feeling great about a tournament plus
two something just didn't go her way
Queen D3 the Knight A3 early 93 just
didn't work out for her it did not no
and uh Anna wow
uh jump in on on what we've just
witnessed oh Mira that was that was
something that was really amazing
actually uh well I have this position on
the board first of all of course well
you can play King F3 here because even
if you exchange on the on D5 this this
end game is actually very easy to win
because you forgot that I am being in
this town yes with the check so
actually this reminds me forcibly of the
game yesterday two connected past pawns
versus
against Bella yeah so Bella shows that
she knows how to win that ending yeah
we'll demonstrate her technique in this
engine but I think of course it's easily
winning and here in this game that was
the
ah well such a dramatic
finish so after Queenie one Queen D6
rookie 6 white is still winning Queen D7
so here humpy committed the first
inaccuracy and a huge one so that's what
I was trying to show you so after rookie
seven
Queen D6 checked check check rookie
eight so well I showed you the variation
uh that was so you were trying to reach
the trunk here
and then what happens if you don't take
and you play uh King G7 here you will
always forget about those moves like
it's a very nice geometry but you're
winning here you're simply maybe this
was the move that rumpi missed in her
calculation right so now if you take of
course on it and I made a new in two
and this was a very important move to
well to see there is after D3 she's
still here has has had the draw here I
think she had to retreat the rook and to
take on G3 and reevaluate but she still
thought that she's winning I don't know
she made this move and well the same
idea D4 and then Queen C8 or like in the
game Queen City and then D4 wins the
game immediately
wow wow and our we have two games
remaining and they're both our
tournament leaders and they're both
going down and they're both going down
uh we don't say that often and Stavanger
um we had the number one and number two
players in the world uh Ali Reza farouza
by rating I want to say and Magnus
Carlson both lost
in the opening round and it was like you
don't usually say you know uh you're
you're two top players but that's what
is happening here in round four as a
very eventful round from the Cairns cup
wow uh
I'm just thinking about this moment when
when Arena because we didn't really it
was time trouble we really didn't get a
chance to we weren't looking at H5 we
weren't looking in this direction I
really liked how Bella played this she
entire attack she played intuitively
and yes she made a mistake apparently E6
was a blunder but when your opponent
only has 30 seconds on the clock you
don't necessarily have to make the most
accurate moves you have to play the
opponent exactly
and it worked but here I guess it was
the moment that Arena had a chance to
save the game it was King takes H6 how
did how how would the variation have
continued after King 8 we're just
sidestepping Queen D3 check and queen G6
mate so we go King takes H6 do we go
Rook to D7 do we go we try but I can
just go
Queen H2 even
after Rook the seven Queen H2 oh my
goodness so that's that's
completely safe on H6 yeah
but as we as we try to decipher what
should have was going on in this game uh
let's go to Almera with uh guest in
studio Almira over to you Oh Nana
welcome once again what a dramatic uh
end of the game that you had did you
know that you were losing at some point
and then I mean
I didn't like my position exactly where
I I was losing I don't know but if she
would have taken if takes G5 instead of
F5 I didn't like my position okay so uh
walk us through the game what were the
critical points did you know the opening
yeah because I had a similar opening
with the Wagoner I mean a couple of
weeks ago and during the women's Grand
Prix and I didn't take on F4 after
Bishop F4
here and then after the game after that
game when I analyzed computer suggested
Bishop F4 and Bishop G4 and that's why I
played it today what did you play Queen
is seven uh Queen if actually I don't
remember exactly now because this is I
know I think I took but I didn't call
Bishop G4 now I remember okay I took but
I didn't go Bishop G4 I went Knight B6
if I remember correctly so but uh Bishop
G4 this I remember for sure that
computer was suggesting that's why I
played Bishop G4 and actually after all
these exchanges okay continue
uh I liked my position
after 94 I thought I had no problems but
then after uh
after she after Rook E5 when she played
I couldn't find any plan for me I was
thinking to play like A5 A4 but I
thought it's too slow I liked her move
Bishop F3 very much
because this bishop F3 I think it
prevents my C5
counter play and also now she wants to
come with this Pawn G4 H4 F5 so I I
couldn't find any any good plan for
black hair I don't know I was I I think
I I I thought here more than 20 minutes
but yeah but what I should I should make
a move so that's why I played Rook AC 8.
otherwise I I don't know I was thinking
technique but I didn't know what to do
man so yeah after
um
here already I I did like my position
and okay I have a question for you here
because did you consider that why it
could leave The Rook on E5 sure of
course maybe try something yes if yes I
was considered actually here I think G5
I was going to play
so you consider these options I think
this was a very nice continuation but
then uh no no after okay F5 and when uh
continue please
here I think F5 was wrong
from her side because after F take
divide that's what I was calculating I
should play Knight either f8 or B6 and
then she exchanged these Rook send them
Queen E7 and I have I think losing
position yes because we have to show our
audience that the main threat in this
position is actually Queen six yes let's
say we make a move like so Queen is six
is winning on the spot so or maybe he
should even even queen of three yes
probably
even here I could take he takes a form
but after Queen is six I thought I was
losing no all right Queen E6 Bishop P6 I
was calculating this line
and what no hit F6 yeah
he considers that you have to give an
exchange exchange Rook V7 I thought this
was losing for me that's why I didn't
I didn't go on this this line
yes it's not easy for a human eye to
understand why is this worse actually I
agree with you completely
no no but it's
I understand of course so if five
negative six yeah after F5 uh yeah after
Knight F6 I already
started thinking survival surviving here
we started to breathe
and then I think if I okay five still
still in tough position so let's get
back to that at least my knight is in
the place so and I think that the most
dramatic thing happened here
the computer shows yes that white is
winning after rookies seven yes rookie
seven I was going to play what what I
was thinking I think Queen G4 I was
thinking
no no no he wants to give check no no no
no no yeah yes and then the problem is
that this variation I think that maybe
both of you missed is that what you made
no it's like Queen
of Queen this uh yes and if I couldn't
deserve and if I go queenie7 well then
he starts collecting collecting all the
phones yeah
and what did you feel here actually did
you know that you were after Queen is
three years three it looked very strange
it was after that yeah yeah I noticed
Quincy Adam there already I thought it's
raining for me
so well it's a very important Victory
Nana yeah she was in time trouble and
that's why yeah she I didn't see this
I'm always asking a few questions you
know
has nothing to do with the game uh well
you are one of the most famous
representatives of the Georgian uh chess
school so I wanted to ask you what were
the chess Traditions when you were
um growing up is there some something
that you would like to share with us
actually I've shared several times this
my chess story because my name Nana my
father gave me afternoon Alexandria
because at that time when I was born
just was like hugely popular in Georgia
because we we had this golden Georgian
women team day one I think
several times Olympic Championship also
we had our famous world champion my
YouTube
so just was very popular and yeah my
father was
um fun fun of them and that's why he
wanted me to become
chest player in the world champion
so the Franklin from the beginning it
was decided that I should become just
for myself so he is proud of you know
and when you won the world Blitz
Championship also what did he say
yeah
unfortunately my father passed away
before that yeah but this achievement it
really was the
biggest achievement in my chest career
so I'm really very proud of this thank
you Nana yes you I think you make us all
proud and especially Georgian fans they
support you I know this we share a lot
of success and especially hope for
another medal in well in individual
events and also in the team events thank
you very much a question for you Nana if
you don't mind we just had Carol Meyer
she's the executive director of the USCF
we talk about women's chess and how to
make chess more popular for women in
America in your home country of Georgia
women flock to the game and you have a
great cultural tradition of supporting
chess in Georgia how can America
help women play chess and make it as
popular as it is in Georgia Almira if
you could ask the question to uh yes
yeser asks so how can American
well American chess American society
help women more you know and to do the
same as like Georgian chess tradition
[Music]
um
actually
nowadays it's it's very different as it
was before because
before when I when I was playing like
when I was a kid that time we didn't
have much choice you know
but nowadays your children kids they
have many different options to choose
not only chess
but in America I think here especially I
mean what's this here they are doing I
mean they are very much promoting chess
I think and I think they should continue
like this and actually the first day
when we met
Mr sinkfield and Mrs I I asked them
maybe
in the future they will organize some
strong women tournaments rapid and Blitz
in Rapid English I think it's it boosts
just in America because I love playing
good afternoon please and I think for
the viewers for the I mean Spectators
it's very entertaining to see I mean
women playing rapid and Blitz so yeah
wow that's a very nice suggestion thank
you uh
wrap it in blitz so uh Rex and Genie uh
pay attention here by the way uh going
to the game of uh Alexandra for just a
moment I'm looking at this move F2 F3 we
all know whenever your head material uh
trade it's it's it's the simplest thing
in the world trade also I mean on a is
so safe her King is so safe now if we
could just trade one pair of Rooks and
leave this Knight on H4 and this Rook on
F4 high and dry and say okay Rook to D2
Rook takes Knight takes Ah that's just
great black has no bad move in this
position no bad move and if you don't
like them apples and I love Rook d uh
too by the way the other
alternative is night you can also if you
have H5 as well with 93 oh nice I wasn't
even looking at the age point
how many times
no but uh yeah it it just feels like
it's a completely overwhelming position
and honestly
each time controls she's thinking it
over but for me Rook D2 for you
simplifies things I like 93. you like my
Rook on A2 is fantastic it is it is I'll
give you that there's no question it is
fantastic and so Knight G3 ideas of
while I agree that when you have extra
material you should exchange pieces in
this position every single white piece
is terrible I don't want to exchange
anything yeah the reason why I really
like Rook D2 uh on a level is that this
bishop on A3 I was looking even to
exploit it
by you know playing for the Knight C4
Bishop comes back Knight takes B4 but
really it is completely overwhelming and
I wouldn't be shocked if this is like
one of those computer positions of plus
seven plus eight plus nine it's really
terrible and definitely uh Alexandra
knows it better than anybody she knows
that everything has gone wrong
and let's just jump back to the arena
game because again our two tournament
leaders coming in today's game arena
Alexandra both losing and this is almost
it's not a it's not an identical uh
position to yesterday's Rook ending but
it's a very serious Echo two connected
past pawns versus one uh Pawn rook's
gonna be on B7 and you're just going to
two and I think here up the board Flex
King is absolutely terrible in the
corner also even if Irina had time to
improve the king and put it in front of
white spawns it still lost exactly even
if the King was on E5 or F6 no different
so technically speaking another
winning ending but it's somehow that
middle game that crazy crazy middle game
that has occurred it's remarkable for me
that Arena was able to fight her herself
to sadly a losing ending
I agree but it's very practical
Bella made a lot of practical choices in
this game yes she was in time trouble
she didn't want to miss some possible
counter play so she went for the queen
exchange and she knew that this end game
she can win exactly and that's exactly
what she's one win per game is all
you'll ever need is said a world
champion and Legend Michael tall and he
was right one win per game so maybe it
wasn't everybody's spectacular choice
but good enough and Anna zatonski uh wow
to think that she comes into the
tournament the lowest seed by rating
um and she could be
so little leader wow I think Nana had
one and a half points and she won so she
has two and a half so Nana and Anna
wait no honest can still be in the first
place exactly clear third right now yeah
Anna came into this round clear third
not tied with Nana but clear third so
she would jump to three out of four and
uh Alexandra and Arena would stay at two
and a half so there'll actually be a
three-way tie for the second place yes
whoo but it just shows how one move
changes the result of the game as in
conairo Technica yeah that uh yeah but
it was F2 F3 was kind of the Prelude to
the massive blunder yeah okay so F3 I
knew it was going and it was like the
Anna satonski versus Bella game F5 check
with the Prelude to throwing away the
wind that didn't get thrown away
completely as uh but look at our day so
far uh
the results the results we have three
results two draws and one win by
nanotechnitzel expecting two more wins
in the two remaining games though yeah
don't expect Fortress
I do not expect Fortress and to remind
everybody of our schedule
rest is coming up on Thursday June 8th
tomorrow they will play around five and
then there will be a rest day after
which they'll come back to play four
rounds in a row and play off if
necessary on June 13th I love the fact
that we have the luxury of a playoff all
on its own and by the way that was a big
question for me would on a play a rook
D2 or Knight G3 she liked your move
Knight G3 on the board very quickly came
thank you if she was in time trouble she
would exchange pieces and go Rook D2 but
since she has more than 20 minutes
well I liked your explanation your
explanation was pretty darn good all of
Black's pieces are better than their
opposition so why trade them I trade
them because I I know that I would win
um by by taking pieces off the board I
Knight takes H5 I like that uh not only
winning a pawn but again just leaving
this night on H4 in some
I don't know no man's land uh
so she's up two pawns and G5 even if she
wasn't up any pawns she would still be
winning that's how good her position is
exactly uh it's like one of those uh
French defenses where you've got it how
did the bishop end up on A3 the bishop
ending up on A3 is fine but that
diagonal is supposed to be open not
closed so the combination of the Pawn on
B4 and the bishop on A3 is terrible
Knight takes H5 terrible terrible
terrible uh for Alexandra to defeat
Alexandra with the black pieces is very
difficult but especially when she's in
good form and she's been playing so well
the first three games complete fireworks
on the board and
yeah it just means Anna is even in a
better shape yeah by the way just
occurred to me that after Knight takes
H5 in order to stop the winning move G5
I'm required to play F4 right and then
comes F5
like wait a minute your Rook you to stop
me from taking a rook or to take your
Pawn you have to play on Passat right
there's just no other choice Knight
takes there's a Tempo against your Rook
where is your Rook gonna go Rook G3 I
was gonna say if you go Rook G6 uh 97 97
Rook G3
yeah
Knight comes I can't even look at what I
know I mean it's so Grim it's like
everything everything everything has
gone wrong and uh Almera I mean it's one
of those positions where you know the
assessment is plus four plus five
and if we look at the difference between
these two games going on there's one's
rather beer isn't it it looks like Buck
house where yes they uh Alexandra and
Anna took all the pieces from Bella's
game from both games right yeah yeah and
those Bug House Games sometimes you see
you know one board is completely full
the other is a bit naked well that's
French defense for you there you go uh
in the game of Alexandra
um uh Almera it's one of those positions
where you know it's overwhelming and you
know if you said to me plus four plus
five I would believe it but I have a
strong suspicion it might be more she's
about to win a piece this is more the
computer relates this position is my
more than minus nine but more than minus
now when I think about this game
um first of all I wanted to tell you
that this line is one of the lines that
uh
Anna's husband Daniel Friedman plays so
first of all a very intelligent opening
choice I think and this is how
everything can go wrong in the advanced
French because that's why I studied
these positions for a while and I
realized that if uh well you choose the
wrong plan then you simply don't have a
chance for a country play and this game
perfectly illustrates it it was simply a
wrong plan because I think Queen C3 with
Queen B4 that was not the thing to do
and then black is already winning
happen quickly this current position by
the way I'm looking at a look I I mean
clear the cobwebs G7 G5
that the Knight on H
4 we've mentioned has no Retreats I
think that's I think of 35 Alexandra
might just resigned for sure uh there's
no forward moves and there's no retreat
so G7 G5 uh wow
I'm kind of stunned I mean very very
good of course for Anna satonski but
this has got to be a second wind going
on a career-wise just thinking about And
Then There She Goes
and I know that G5 F4 immediately like I
got this says Alexandra no you don't go
on I don't know if this helped Anna but
yesterday I got a message after the game
she invited me to play ping pong with
her yes I did I couldn't go but I know
that she played and that was her prep
for today right wow
by the way how's your ping pong
about as good as honest we are on the
same level we played during your stamps
yeah it's competitive it's competitive
okay okay and I was supposed to be the
referee
an Arbiter It's always important to have
fair play F4
and uh well I'm thinking just take the
night right Knight takes F4 dude Knight
takes F4 there's also F5 multiple I can
just play five now I was looking at F5 a
moment ago F5 looks great I'm sorry
look H4 I don't want to give the H6 no
no I don't give the H6 Pawn I give
nothing I'm gonna go Knight G7 put my
knight on F5 yeah
of course this is completely winning
completely winning but you said a five
as well yeah five oh boy oh boy by the
way Knight takes F4 yes I mean it just
there's a plethora of uh winning moves
and I think B6 would ruin into like
there's no bad move here well give me a
moment give me a moment I'm sure I'll
I'll find something uh but yeah this is
uh okay I mean uh
Alexandra's given up she's just she's
she she wants to see a cheap bow
opportunity uh the moment uh Anna does
something that just
like an F5 move uh like a knight takes
F4 or takes on H4 I think she'll toss in
the towel and maybe we should check on
the Bella's end game please let's do it
uh we'll jump over today I might take
a few minutes just to make sure she's
completely winning exactly and we do
have rookie five and uh Bella dancing or
Pawn she did it yesterday uh in a very
clear precise precise manner yes exactly
just a four a five yep let's do it F4
Rook B5 what else F5 now if you put your
king I'm gonna give you a check
drive you away can get four and I don't
want to see E5 yeah is it even Checkmate
oh yeah so yeah uh I'll I'll do it this
way
so if I play Rook B7
could we have an echo you are in
stalemate but you do have a passer as
well if something like that happens
again I'd be available
too and then her opponent catches it so
yeah Rook B7 I think I'm uh are we
missing another
so if Rook was on B5 black no it still
doesn't work no no I don't think yeah
you're ready to play Rook takes H yeah I
know and so V6 and now we've got
everything uh that we want so yeah we're
expecting F4 followed by F5 and Arena
knows this very very well
and there you go F4
an intro to today's round who would have
guessed that two our co-leaders would be
losing their games not me not me not me
I did not see this type of a round
whatsoever
wow
it's quite rare because when you started
the tournament well with couple of wins
yeah
it usually continues that way exactly
things go your way exactly and again uh
Alexandra had come in
uh with two victories with the white
pieces she's just drawn round three with
the black pieces she's got the white
pieces again today and it's sort of like
the table is set the banquet I think her
opening Choice was just
a mistake it was just wrong
they are uh so I'm D4 player but I've
definitely played a lot of E4 as well
right and there are certain players who
play E6 especially E6 the French defense
so well that against them I never played
before and Anna is one of those players
oh this is embarrassing
um uh Armenian players
um Rafiq vaganian but then there was
he's I believe the president of the
Chess Federation of Armenia Grand Master
and I can't remember
putian it was fantastic
simbad he would sit there in the most
stoic way he had this incredibly stiff
back and he would sit there very very
very stoically and he would play his
French defense and beat everybody
including one Gary kasparo wow and asked
after the game
why did you play the French defense
against zimbab and he answered I made a
bad decision
yeah it does send that and for that
matter Rafiq vaganian they they're
French defense uh caught a lot a lot of
players of kilter F5 check on the board
Arena losing has Anna
no she didn't make a she said Kenner
time wow because she knows game is
almost over she just needs to make one
or two more accurately she doesn't even
need Ikea moves but she's looking for
the best moves to just finish the game
right I'm I'm thinking F5 also maybe
after her game against Bella she just
wants to yeah yeah be absolutely
absolutely absolutely appreciate
everything right just not to allow
anything
it was nothing too I liked about your B6
move that's a very strong okay no I I
kind of liked it because in the game in
the position that I was looking at takes
on H4 take a piece Rook takes night back
now of course you want to play Rook H3
but Knight F5 kind of annoys you so you
prep it you play the move G4
right and then it's sort of like well if
I play H5 right there is this move
Bishop f8 that I don't know if it
concerns you or not and I start to think
well if the bishop was not on you know
there'd be nothing yeah
right like distract the bishop throw it
away I think she's gonna go for a fight
at four no very safe I couldn't guess
couldn't guess uh Knight takes F4
so rocks hanging inside is hanging the
height is hanging I guess Rook F3 what I
would play okay
let's do it
92 check here and just pick up the
Knight on H4
and blessed I I yeah of course 92 check
and just take the Knight and uh that's
all that's not even
there's no fun at all no it's it's no
fun in Mudville
this is just bad bad bad bad bad Almera
I mean we I mean the positions is bad
bad we don't see a single trick that
Alexandra could set for for Anna Knight
takes F4 was amongst the number of wins
is there any
I mean is there any tricks that uh that
uh Alexandra could pull off well that's
what I think Anna was thinking about
because she wanted to be sure that there
is absolutely no idea for black to lose
this game she was juggling the pieces
around so I tried something like this
for example if you uh Knight T2 here
after Rook F3 King H2 you take on H4 uh
Rook H4 for example uh
there is this threat of playing Rook F6
Okay computer suggested at some point
simply to take on uh G4 and then give
everything and play but then yes Rook C2
you suggest here so and
here after Rook F6 he simply says C5 yes
and uh well he he's he thinks that
anyway
yes it speaks for itself after D4 there
is no mate so you can take I will run
away happily with my king anyway so it's
important simply to sacrifice The Rook
for this bishop and well it's the matter
of technique the witness between Anna's
reach absolutely uh yeah that looks that
looks awful in the position Knight takes
Rook E3 Knight check followed by G takes
H4 so rookie 3's idea is that if you
play 92 I go King F1 and I can pick up
the piece as well if you take on H4
trading pieces sounds like a great deal
to me I wouldn't allow this you wouldn't
how come
because I have ugly poems you have many
many
ugly pawns uh right okay so you you're
looking not maybe it's okay too instead
of 92. I like rookie too much I like
rookie too rookie too is a very nice
move
I like rookie too a lot
oh my goodness and in the same line if
you go King F1 I'm just gonna move the
Knight I love it
I don't know
no just see three yes yes that's it you
know the best you can do is put your
knight on F3 but now the Rook is again a
little bit cornered and trapped 94. I
mean it's Checkers all of blacks pieces
are on light squares Untouchable end of
story uh arena is going down and she's
trying to make Bella's life slow
progress
exactly snail light progress but I like
how Bell is torturing you and I just
even repeating moves here and there
I know I know uh our predecessors would
would love to torture uh their opponents
and they would play you know an extra
repetition
and as we start winding up this round
four where we're expecting three
victories let's take a peek at ahead at
the pairings for tomorrow's round let's
take a look we have Mama Zada playing
cornero
all right Irina Crush against Elizabeth
pets and the two Georgians will be
playing each other's agnies against
Billy now I know for a fact those two
have played each other many many times
you think yeah for how many Georgian
national champions they've always
competed for the first and second place
in charge and championships exactly wow
okay nice nice and that will be the day
before the free day too by the way so
those those those games that those
rounds that take place before the free
day they tend to be long yes
exceptionally so because everybody knows
they've got that extradated recover and
Arena Crashers Rook C6 uh again I I'm
I'm reaching Almira for arena here but
it looks like it's just one of those
table based positions she's doing doing
our best not to allow villages to
applaud and move her pawns forward she's
played the move before I guess we're
going to get into that uh zuk swung
position sure I think of six Rook B7
Rooks is seven yes king of six and Rook
B7 is a very clean way to improve for
your position actually I wanted to tell
you a story that I remember it's we
shouldn't be fooled by Anna's rating
she's such a strong player and what's
um
impressed me the most is that I've seen
her game with black against Boris
girlfriend and she defended for such a
long time and she actually won this game
and I think this is the impossible to
beat boys girlfriends it's something
that you achieve only once in a lifetime
I think it's a treasure yeah it's a
treasure yes so she is tremendously
strong and sometimes they and that's why
I think that's very important to offer
national champions this unique
opportunity to come to compete in the
super events because there are very few
of them exactly exactly they make the
most of your opportunities when they do
knock and uh Anna zatonski here playing
against a former world champion
Alexandra and geez wow she's saving her
best and we do have some more moves by
the way after the move F4 Knight takes
F4 rookie three none of the moves we
were thinking about we were thinking
about B6 we're thinking about Rook E2
even 92 we were thinking
97. 97 just saying okay your only play
your only play is on the king side I'm
going to plug up uh the position uh so
that you can't do any kind of
breakthrough and she played 97 I
supposed to bring her Knight to F5 until
almira's point when she was saying to
not underestimate Anna because of her
rating I recently read an article on
chess base that
they did research to show Almost
inflated and deflated ratings in all the
countries and USA was number one most
deflated ratings most underrated
inflated ratings wow how did we manage
that because we have USCF ratings
and a lot of tournaments in the US
exactly and we have so many powerful
Junior players they don't have their
feed a rating updated with their USC up
ratings yes when I play open tournaments
I'll be facing someone I checked their
feeder rating is only 2 000 so I expect
an easy game right I don't win then I
check their UCF it's 2400. exactly it's
like wait a minute and that's how we
lose a lot of iterating points I get it
now okay that that's what happens by the
way uh sorry but I mean it's a beautiful
picture if you look at Black's nights
what uh Anna has just done with the
Black Knights it it it's really it's
really very pretty for a night lover
this is right I mean as a French defense
player myself I'm just happy with one
good night on F5 like that to my mind is
you know uh just I expect action she has
trapped white Rook like right G4 cannot
move exactly so you start to think to
yourself like okay you know should I be
I think she can play pg6 King H5
that was exactly what I was thinking how
do I attack the roof well I can attack
my king the move King G6 and King H5 the
other thing that I find compelling sorry
to go back to the silly move B6 which is
the second but on a good day if this
Rook ever landed on the seventh ring
you know it's like you know how how how
delish that would be so we would have
dream Rooks and dream nights yes yes
exactly just getting well I mean getting
everybody into the party uh I would find
myself uh very attracted to the move B6
finally I'm looking at the king for just
a second can I suggest
okay I can pick it up rookie three oh
God okay okay good morning St Louis
I was thinking I wanted to get in a rook
check and somehow but yeah Rook takes E3
I I guess what I mean to say I'm going
to wait for you to play book Diggs B5
before jumping with my 19. she goes King
to six I like this I like where this is
going
oh my goodness and uh by the way
four and a half minutes
yeah but you know somewhere in Germany
one Daniel Friedman is saying Anna I
wake up wake up uh don't don't don't do
that I think he knows her so he's not
ordered it no yeah he's feeling very
good King G6 uh intimating and by the
way uh if you do play Rook takes B fight
now Knight E3 starts to look very very
attractive uh once more so what else
white even play I don't know I have no
idea I guess Bishop B6 or something just
I was trying to attractive to that
square uh yeah I
to your point when you miss 93 I think a
lot of people underestimate uh after
playing a four or five hour game right
how easy it is to plunder the most
obvious thing to sure for sure because
when we had that uh incident with Bella
and Anna the stalemate I saw it was
shared on social media and people
commenting it's hard to believe that
Grandmasters can miss something like
this right well you have to consider
this is five hours into the game intense
work and they come sadly to say a lot of
the players do come tired because
they've been doing all of their
preparation so it's not like they just
came and they magically work for five
hours no they came after working for
three hours and even longer so yeah they
are tired
players that your brain does not work as
efficiently at the end of the game as it
does in the beginning absolutely
absolutely
um King H2 this King H5 now is she gonna
go for it
yeah well that that's
no mates or anything right with the
other Rook I don't see any options well
indeed the thing is that after King H5
let's say Rook takes Pawn takes you
start to think okay if you take this if
I could hit this Pawn
I could also do maybe 93 and right away
93 yeah I was just I was just thinking
that the moment I get the double Rooks
uh you know
this work on D7 is the one guy that's
not you know pulling its weight put it
on G8 and yeah King H5 three minutes by
the way
keeping us on the edge of our seed
three minutes counting down
no update in Arena's game Bella just
slowly making progress yes she is
she is
it's uh incredible how after two days
round literal change the second place
will change everything's Changes
Everything Changes and because all this
uh women are so close in strength with
each other anyone can beat anyone yeah
around
well no question about that I do not
expect that
um Zen Saya is going to be a
gifting uh so many points I think that
she's going to be she's done yes she's
going to be a force to reckon with them
just like Bella terrible beginning and
here she is spoiling the tournament for
Irena exactly and uh going back to the
game of Anna for just a moment because
again she was down to three minutes
she's completely winning
but in some ways because she's down to
two and a half minutes she is
encouraging uh Alexandra to continue to
play like right I mean if if Anna had uh
30 minutes on her clock there would be
no reason to continue
right but the fact that she's down to
two
makes you think okay where's my Cheapo
musician doesn't have any chippos
yeah Knight H4 Knight G1 Knight H3 you
start you start looking for it he had a
wide squared Bishop maybe if she would
have something yeah but with this bishop
that
pieces are on the White Square so the
bishop is just
completely useless yeah
one of one of my
singular greatest failures is a game I
had against world champion Anatoly
karpov and I literally had a position
similar to this where I had an
absolutely dominant night
versus a terrible terrible passive
Bishop from a French defense and I
conspired against myself
to get him to draw the game it was it
was
horrifying it was really the worst ever
but yeah this night on F5 dominating uh
the position 91. she should continue the
march with the king king G4 why not it's
it's very powerful there the one reason
I'm I might just hesitate just just a
little bit is because again I'm So yeah
so attracted to getting the Rook but
you're right if I played the move Knight
D3 I'm almost compelling
King G4 right if I play King G4 and then
you go Knight D3 I just have F3 and that
wins on the spot that's that's nothing
to discuss that's Rook takes G2 and
that's horrifying so King G4 and 44
seconds but expecting King G4 not
worried think that the only way she
doesn't win this game is if she forgets
about her clock completely
who did that recently somebody told us I
think Dean did that at the world
championship yes
yes at the world championship the
highest level of Chess ding laryn
literally forgot about his clock and at
93 by the way this looks
very very good paralysis the night only
one exactly no no Knight D3 for you Rook
takes G2 check on tap for
and King H3 okay getting out of the
possible no I think it's time for Rook
d8 yes finally Rook d8
Rook G8 and by the way now like a magnet
a rook is drawn to the G3 Square because
it's even checked
something to be said no
I was about to say rookie two no
uh I'm a pond Grabber so it just
naturally comes to me it's a it's it's a
part of my DNA now you know how can I
win a pawn you know I can win a pawn
like this but I love her of d8
minute and a half for Anna but I'm
expecting Rook d8
rookie one also looks good is Rook a one
Rook A1 oh my goodness hello forget I
guess what was Bishop B for
okay but that's really and then you can
play Rook C7 maybe that's what I'm
talking about anything that uh liberates
my I don't know D7 not overthink this
because she can't make any movement win
the game
I've had I I want to say evil thoughts
on the evil dream I've had is this idea
that my opponent completely winning has
is now
my opponent winning is letting their
clock ticks kick down
five seconds four seconds
and of course they're going to make the
winning move of which there's many and I
suddenly make this incredibly loud
sneeze like just to distract them for
that absolute Split Second
and oh you're I'm sorry your flag fell
that's genius that's evil evil genius
and then the opponent complains to the
Arbiter but my opponent you didn't do
anything illegal he just sneezed I
couldn't I couldn't help myself I
sneezed well how would the Arbiter rule
what what would the officer says
anything to rule you just fly upon in
flag you fly oh I'm sorry you I'm sorry
uh by the way some moves let me just
refresh
and uh Alexander played G3 King G5 G3
because the Knight is actually sitting
on E3
um okay I guess she's just going to
one day I mean uh we played Rook e E2 or
something that forces a resolution I
like rookie too because it also protects
the night on E3 I mean it's just a
simple defensive move as something
uh well Knight F5 Knight G4 battery
threatening Rook H2 mate
nope she went tonight
wait a minute wait a minute Knight F3
check just King G6 just King G6 yeah of
course
but then we're forgetting that
black is also up so much material it
changes the winning position and blocks
up
in exchange and three pounds I mean
that's well but but it is a it is a
strange decision let me just say to play
93 and then Knight F5 and I mean it's
like she forgot the fact that she's a
rook or an exchange
uh so yeah it's kind of all right I mean
fine
but uh Knight F3 King G6 I like it
she takes F and then maybe she just
needs to start using her other Rook
exactly anything that brings that Rook
into play I'm all for anything that
B6 even you know bring the Rook to the
A5 over to the C file get that Rook into
play
King G6 on the board sorry I
uh pause because there is G4 as a I
don't know G4 no she did take
and I'm thinking King H5 and
well yeah King can go to H7 just to be
safe
not that it's not safe from H5 but right
yeah yeah
Brook
get the Rook into play Anna
and please don't go down to 30 seconds
because two seconds right
because then who knows maybe Alexandra
has
evil ideas
of the devastating sneeze you know I've
heard the story it happened at the arrow
float open it's a very strong tournament
yes so the time control was that until
move 40 there was no increment there was
no extra 30 seconds right
in some player one of the grand Masters
on move 39 completely went in position
but went down to one second oh dear so
has to make one more move but it's a
very obvious next move of course so you
know what the opponent did made the most
outrageous move like giving up the queen
with the check yes but it means that
opponent has to take the queen and be
able to click the clock in less than one
second right and he flacked and he
flagged yeah because you you make a move
like where you capture something and the
move that you wanted to make is no
longer available uh by the way Rook F2
and I don't like the way I mean Anna
makes me nervous I'm telling you she
okay she did it fortunately with 20
seconds on her clock she didn't let her
time go you know egregiously low which
would be 10 seconds but it's sort of
like she went Rook F2
she went Rook F2
slowly she she she held The Rook on the
F2 Square
and only pressed the clock after like
three seconds of making sure she wasn't
blundering anything she doesn't Inspire
confidence and she doesn't make the
opponent you know Inspire the opponent
to resign like that's what she wants he
wants her opponent to resign right yes
so you you play Rook F2 bang you know
you hit the clock this is it it's it's
great I'm doing really really well
um Amira jump in here on on uh why why
is Anna making us so nervous is it
something
tell tell me tell me why
ah because I think that well she wants
to be absolutely sure that there is no
blunder is you as you said even though
she she knows that she's completely
winning you have to understand how
important this win is to her right now
given the tournament situation and also
that she's playing against the former
world champion who is leading the
tournament you have to take a lot all of
these factors into consideration to
understand how much pressure she feels
especially in the time travel
and she wants to make everyone happy as
well
but is it dare I say a lack of
confidence in some ways that she has to
double check and triple check and
quadruple check everything she she's
such a strong player she knows she's
winning absolutely materially it's
overwhelming again it could be because
of Bella's game
that in that Rook end game that that she
missed the style man so it scared her
yes yeah Rook F2 and again we can switch
game for a moment yeah just a second
sorry I I'm looking at 1918. I wouldn't
worry about her you wouldn't worry about
the clock I worry about the clock
worry about the clock okay uh we'll
switch uh I see our our production well
why did Bella didn't need to win this
Pawn why is she I think Irina sacrificed
the pawn hoping that maybe she can
or some kind of a draw but there is no
draw if you play rookie one or Rook F1 I
guess rookie one is all right yeah okay
sure she wants Bella to play E6 now E6
would be a terrible blunder rookie five
and take on F5 proof
H7 check
after rookie one Rook F7 or actually I
don't need okay seven rookie six yeah
rookie six looks like uh but Rook H7 no
oh just rookie six Jack rookie six Jack
you defend upon somewhere F7 and I just
bring my king king C6 yeah or King C6
and you bring your king over to escort
uh the Pawns to coronation that's that's
pretty simple
and if I go the other way and I go Rook
to F1 trying to provoke F6 now I'll play
Rook H7 and then play F6
and oh no I didn't want to go
there there okay
yeah six okay five this should still be
winning rookie seven and yeah I agree
nothing to discuss gonna go back to our
game with Anna for a moment because
finally on a dig yay Bishop B6 rookie
seven Bishop A5 rookie eight The Rook is
involved very nice Rook E2 on the board
I'm expecting King H5
Rook
G8
and that's
you know Rook takes B5 on the board
oh now there's a simple tactic Rook E3
she didn't play it there's a rookie
three King G2 Rook takes F3
I see you've done your puzzle Rush
tactics there Nasi very very nice by the
way that is that would have gotten a
handshake on the spot you're absolutely
right a very pretty little Fork I think
um to uh
for from Anna's perspective I
you know she sees something similar but
with this King actually in a Czech
mating box she sees Rook A8 to A3 can't
can't criticize her for that but you're
absolutely right Rook takes F3 would
have been a clincher
well it's going to play Rook B3 here to
not allow Rook A3 right and then I'm
just going to run you out of moves
actually King age you're still put in
White's King in stalemate yes I can get
rid of all three pieces that you've got
a bishop you're not even close to
getting your much coveted stalemate in
that in that game in that case
um and you can almost feel Alexandra is
just like her mind is screaming you know
like how how can I trick my opponent at
this point she's just like just win this
game so I don't have to sit here and
suffer anymore right Bishop A5 on the oh
excuse me Bishop A5 on the board we
could still rookie three Rook F3 is
winning indeed but we've kind of pounded
the table a little there for the move B7
B6 and what a time to actually get the
move B6 in it's almost like a crowning
achievement
she's reaching for the bee Pawn right
that's actually for me that's uh that's
a little stylish you know like I love
your rookie three it takes F3 no
question about it that that that's
pretty simple too but this one
and it gets my vote yeah
wow what a turnaround and for Anna just
think what would have happened if Bella
had made that Rook takes A3 I think it
would have been devastating Anna would
have like gone home and you know cursed
her bad luck and there we have it B7 B6
has provoked oh no sorry it's a new
score sheet I thought she was signing
the score sheet yeah I think they
originally moved 60 and she ran out of
this B6 Bishop B4
and now just Rook A2 or K1
it's one this both of these Rooks are
playing impossible to do anything
exactly Rook
oh I think she says now she sees it
right she's
yes yes better late than never well
actually in this particular case she's
probably seeing King G2
yeah you don't even have Kenji too I'm
just gonna take the Knight
our congratulations to Anna zutanski
which means that one of our tournament
leaders has tumbled out of first leaving
Arena
left
and there's nothing to say it's
a table based
win here for Bella after Rook E1 we were
expecting rookie 6 check and then the
white king will come over after Rook E6
Rook H7 is also winning of General cage
seven shots really
King somewhere f8 she played it and now
I push E6 okay rookie five King C6
wow giving away the pond but you're just
you're just gonna yeah I think you're
right I think that's also uh winning but
boy uh I must say I would have been
content
with the move Rook E6 check and then
bringing my king closer
to it you know escorting the pawns uh
computer likes this move
Rook H7 check it's okay yes work H7 is
winning and as it demonstrated quite
accurately how how white should proceed
after King f8 E6 right arrow key five
King C6 of course Rook F5 King D6 but
not King D7 right
yes I think the seven is actually a draw
so that's again D6 is a very important
move okay because why is it a draw
because
check sorry yes because check on D5 yes
the king is kind of right but then King
D6
yeah here
is winning because I don't know a
computer seven check is a threat Rook h
a check is a threat so both are winning
threats yes you cannot play uh Rook F6
here because now you can play Kingdom
yes of course right wow
and so with one game remaining our
results of uh round four and it's gonna
be epic today we had wins with two black
pieces
defeated tournament leader Alexandra
castanoke and we had two draws between
pets and Abdul Malik and Jonathan and in
our remaining game it looks like again
our tournament uh co-leader coming into
the round uh Arena crash is going to go
down to defeat Bella has got two
connected past pawns and they are racing
at the board we're only looking at King
f8 if we go King E8 E6 nah this is
actually even easier
check take the Pawn King D6 and we're
actually threatening to trade Rooks and
escort the pawn home yeah this is
actually even easier King E8
and
for Arena at what point do you say okay
my opponent is demonstrated enough she's
going to play until the king D6 move
till the king D6 move in that variation
after King f8 yeah right
I have a feeling that we don't we're not
getting stumped by our audience uh
they're not uh I mean the Oracle I'm
glad that we we settled that one uh but
uh yeah I would I I found also the
answer that Nana gave to be very
interesting about the Georgian chess
scene and the Georgian women and the
idea was that in the Soviet times if I
could use that expression and pardon me
I don't mean to be offensive but in
Soviet times chess was so popular
because there wasn't so many choices
today with all of the computers and
video games and all the entertainments
uh that we had too many distractions too
many distractions right uh and uh Nana
said well if you want to keep women in
the game give them more opportunities
and play Blitz
[Laughter]
we may play the American Cup I love that
format I love the rapid format as well I
would like to see more of the American
Cup style formats
I think that they lend themselves to
really entertaining and Fighting Chess
and since uh GCT has rapid and Blitz
events I think they should start they
have women's Grand Prix which is just
the classical but they should definitely
introduce rapid and Blitz as well
exactly because right now I think only
rapid and Blitz tournaments that these
women have it's just watching the world
championship yes
but then once why should we limit
ourselves only to Rapid and Blitz way
not the women's crunches tour
which has not only uh rapid and Blitz
but also features classical tournaments
really these uh again it's more more
opportunities more really really really
strong events and when I look at the
junior players today I I see just
fantastic fantastic uh players the Next
Generation uh how well they play and the
young Indian players what they did in
the Olympiad they had like a C team A B
Team yeah they were just spectacularly
fun to watch uh yeah
very very promising moment in the world
of Chess as Arena sitting there saying
okay how can I trick my opponent
how can she trigger opponent
uh King D King EA king f8
um what's the tricky
I guess truecast is King f8 King f8 is
the trickiest okay
and well
it's time right he said I don't think
Bill even has another option so she's
going to play six exactly check and this
is all forcing all forcing King D6
[Music]
um let me see King G8
E7 oh oh you will go into I didn't know
if I mean it's winning
queen versus why go in that right yeah
you kind of think to yourself well wait
a minute okay seven uh King G8 E7 you
know this this requires some
understanding I wouldn't want to play
this necessarily against you know a
computer perfect but you sorry you were
about to take your move back and make a
different move okay seven
and uh let's pause our analysis to go
with Almera and our sole leader at the
moment
yeah yes I'm here with our soul leader
wow congratulations
with the black pieces uh tell us a
little bit about well the game and how
did you prepare somehow somehow I'm not
like I'm having very good score versus
Alexandra I don't know why I think it's
like a four and half before this game I
was plus four so I draw only one game I
probably
she has probably worse score versus me
in her entire the one like all this
Royal fine and things I don't know like
I'm not comfortable like a opponent for
her and this game also proved even in
the beginning it was very shaky for me
yes I don't know she cannot like play
her best chess versus me I don't know
why
so Daniel Was preparing you
no of course like
this was not preparation yes he's
helping me it's very convenient I have
her husband who is a grand master very
strong Daniel Friedman I wanted to thank
him for preparing me for handling all my
bad mood sometimes
this is very nice but I found actually
one of his games in this variation so
let's have a oh really yes yes because
like I I Was preparing something
different and mostly I concentrated on
move Knight C3 and different line in
French defense Alexandra played like
your recent games this was Bishop E2
here so that's why I moved 93 was kind
of surprised even if I'm playing like
French defense in time my career I was
like was sleeping here I didn't know
what which line to use and what to do it
it is actually quite a rare line and
very solid one uh Bishop E2 is not
considered to be the best move here
because of because of what I did or
well you played well yes Bishop before
before it's systematic idea here of
course I like to no but the problem is I
wasn't just like I I didn't know like
how it evaluate the specialization I'm
like my development is very bad I don't
have dark Square Bishop but on the other
hand I have wonderful C4 Square I'm
trying to exchange light squared bishop
and I spend a lot of time because I was
like trying to evaluate this position it
was not like it was not obvious for me
what is evaluation here well it's
perfectly equal for the moment but I
think that you feel maybe these
positions better oh no no I did I didn't
feel that I have good position
especially like with uh like I was down
on clock a lot and I want to show nice
tactics like couple moves like after
Rook B1
but you know like what is what's
interesting in some lines I was even
considering for hero like sacrifice and
queen because like all my pieces on back
Rank and just Queen is running somewhere
but of course maybe it's not kinji one
yes Kenji one yeah probably I should
take only two and continue doing that I
wanted to take off I'm not sure this was
I consider it at least two 1997 yes
bondage for the typical one yeah h4h6
and yes and it's a different game so I
think that Alexander lost the thread of
the game here after Queen CS3 yes I
think she blundered she just realized
that Bishop C2 is a thread
okay so and then and he is very nice
that I'm very happy that I ovulate and
decent game coming before
let's play no right here Queen before I
played group CH so as a spawn sacrifice
and uh after queen bees
here we're thinking okay not to take on
B7 but play c three and I think I am
better here well you are winning here
winning oh
so yeah so this this end game will say
you related this uh correctly I played
many many games thanks uh who was like
training me a lot on this type of
position in one of us Championship we
had like many matches when it was
different system we play like similar
structure a lot yeah
and so when you were completely sure
that you're winning I know that you were
never like I was when I tried Queens
yes yes because like okay Bishop is not
very good I have like pure extra Pawn
why shouldn't I be winning here
okay and then well and then I was like
very nervous I was like kind of shaky
because yeah it was uh not that I didn't
like my position because it was like
very tense game a lot of calculation
before and finally suddenly I am winning
so this was um well I think that was a
perfect a clean positional game uh
congratulations thank you so much and as
he told us that you invited her to play
uh table thank you yes I played it
yesterday table tennis thank you like
guys who was playing with me maybe they
should not do today repeat preparation
yeah well we are hoping to join you
today okay yeah
our congratulations on a very very nice
just a very very quick question for you
I mean uh the sun is shining the birds
are chirping Everything Is Beautiful
uh everything is going your way imagine
Bella had made a draw
in that moment that you gave her you
wouldn't yeah
your your move between what would have
happened and now I'm playing chess for
for how many years for a lot I I had
ever seen my life and moves like
rookestri as well so yes and I should
admit and I have a lot of luck in this
tournament and I have feeling I should
have less points
our congratulations may the sun continue
to shine well done
thank you yeah great game today in the
French defense yeah very much a very
surprised that Arena has fought herself
to King and Rook versus King and Queen
because for me uh the decision it's
winning it's winning there's no question
but the move King G8 Bella could have
just moved her rook and it would have
been impossible to stop Rook check and
and I think Arena would have resigned
actually maybe Bella wants to
demonstrate that she knows how to win
this end game maybe she does but I was
about to say Uh I that there's very very
famous story here in America from 30
years ago
and I think it was the computer Bell
with Ken Thompson who had discovered
that the queen versus Rook had some
uh peculiarities that was unknown to
even players so Walter Brown was invited
to have the king and queen versus the
king and rook and a bet a wager was made
over the outcome and Walter said well
this is ridiculous of course I easily
went and he couldn't do it really they
had a rematch and Walter
Walter studied the ending and won the
rematch but he had to study it first
exactly he had like how do you learned
yes he had to relearn everything that he
thought he knew because the old
knowledge was no was was not correct
so but I think black's King is already
in the corner yeah and very close to
being checked exactly so that's why
Bella so one of the reasons why
um the the old thing was wrong the idea
was that you want to force the Rook away
from the King yeah
but
but what the computer found
is that you can before you're forced
away you voluntarily move away so it was
something like you don't wait uh for
your Rook to get booted but you accept
that you're going to lose it with checks
where can I put the Rook where maybe I'm
not okay go ahead show demonstrate how
you pick up my Rook okay queen of seven
Chuck
well that doesn't
actually Force the win of The Rook does
it or is it wrong G7 Queen H5 and King
F6
uh Rook sorry Rook G7 Queen H5 and King
F6 and King F6 and then you force my now
I'm forcing your Rook to move far away
and now now you pick it up a different
way I suppose yes either
E8 or G4
and he she has played King well pardon
me she played Rook G5 let me just do
this was on G5 she played King G7
exactly
Okay so
is one
oh not that oops oops oops oops sorry
you were about to say every move beside
King E7 or giving up the queen
Queen E7 check
Mage six
in King F6 king of six she's done king
of six king of six
and there's gotta be
a force mate here very soon
yes yes uh unfortunately for Irina she
started uh started the position with her
King in a terrible uh situation already
on the side of the board and let me just
refresh my board game is the rule 50
moves yes okay
in fact uh strangely enough uh I think
the if if I've got this right uh the
table base I if I set up the worst
possibility uh for the superior site
it's a force win in 29 moves
in the worst possibility so 50 is a
generous amount of moves for you to
demonstrate the win
I feel like the computer has really
changed our knowledge like for example
imagine that you have two Bishops and I
have a king at night only that's it do
you think you could win with the two
Bishops
oh
Maybe
[Laughter]
and after this game after Irina loses
this Anna zatoski who will be the only
player in the tournament who still has
not lost a single game the only
undefeated player interesting wow just
after foreign everybody except Anna will
have a big donut uh yeah at one at one
time uh the great analysts of the world
thought that the two Bishops
versus the Knight was a draw and then
the engines showed us that it actually
is winning
it actually wins okay Rook A6 uh and
Almera over to you uh yes yes sir I
simply wanted to show you how to remind
our audience one of the positions that
is essential to win those games so what
you need to achieve is this position
with black to play right so yes King on
F6 let's say uh Queen on H5 King on G8
and Rook on G7 this is one of the
positions where you're going to lose
your Rook for sure
so this is what bill is trying to
achieve right uh we just saw the move
Rook A6 and oftentimes you don't
necessarily go for all the checks but
you do some move like a queen B7 let's
say so the idea is to try to achieve uh
what you're what you're saying put you
put your King on F6 just always be watch
mindful of the stalemates you don't want
to do that but uh
in this particular position is there a
check check to pick up the Rook
just to stop Queen and threatening made
on h8
so if you move your king say King
seventh rank here Queen C7 shark uh oh
are you gonna do a ladder
um a ladder check okay five in King of
six I thought this was yeah no this is
uh essentially what Almira is saying you
know you set up your bella wants to put
her her
um King on F6 so she can set up those
mating patterns with uh Queen h8 and
queen H3 so oh that's a nice one I kind
of like that
uh me like
nice
group A6 on the board
have you ever had Queen and Rook queen
versus Rook no never what about you
I Want to Say Never Never but it sure
doesn't come to my mind and uh that
about 4 000 classical games in my career
it's just not a common ending at all
I've had the rook and Bishop versus Rook
a lot and I haven't had the two nights
versus the pawn you know I actually lost
Rook against rook and Bishop against
Anna yeah one of the Year championships
yeah 48 or something 49. yeah it was
yeah we were counting with you trust me
on that one I relaxed a little bit too
early I was defending correctly and then
I thought oh I just have few more more
moves to make and then I walk right in
here right into oh
devastating and then a week later I got
the exact same end game in a different
tournament but in that one I
um I made a draw okay if I lose this
again I'm quitting chess
and queen D whoa Bella
Bella and uh you found your move Queen
d8 uh quiet move stopping Rook A5 check
but at the same time also setting up a
very very nasty mate in one threat Queen
to h8
how about you Al uh Almera have you in
your uh tournament career a classical
tournament career had to
play king and queen versus King and Rook
either with the Superior or inferior
side no I think that it never happened
in my
my career but I know that I was so
terrified by this possibility that this
position will occur in my game so I've
studied not only this end game but also
a few possibilities of how to break the
Fortress with the rook and upon against
the queen so right because I knew that
um when you play a game and especially
when you're so short on time that you
have to know how to win those positions
because sometimes if you are opponent
defends like a computer
you will and defend stubbornly you you
will have a few moves left before it
will reach the move 50 right
yeah absolutely by the way King G7
are the clocks a factor uh Irina just
made her last move with two seconds on
her clock
we didn't count down I was completely
unawares but Bella has 11 minutes 11
minutes two seconds okay Queen D7 check
now you can't you can't go back to the
eighth rank you have to play King H6
which she did no Quincy eight
kind of that same thing that laddering
uh Queen C8 again
threat of mate on h8 but now we're we're
getting the position that Almera
discussed put the King on F6 in
opposition and all of those check mating
patterns with Queen H3 and queen h8 they
just play themselves so Queen C8 king
move right here
apparently it's made in six
would you feel confident enough to
announce that no no me no me either
eight and six
Queen C8
with 10 minutes on the clock now
58. yeah Bella in the last two games has
shown her I was about to say she really
has I'm impressed the Georgian School of
end games I'm telling you to add to the
tour coaches who actually training maybe
you had the same coach because I
remember when I started to learn chess I
lived in Georgia at the time
they didn't teach me any openings they
told me all the end games
wow very very nice very impressive uh I
have a friend of mine passed away
Michael frenette a champion of
Washington state he said to me yes sir
studying the end games is like cheating
on an exam
because you know you're going to be
tested you know there's going to be an
exam of you know King and Rook versus
King and pawn you've got to know these
uh endings so study your endings
three seconds by the way okay and uh
well Arena knows that that move was it
that was the move right there I would
feel comfortable announcing mate here
exactly exactly
yeah
13th three seconds two seconds but uh
I've seen Irina make it move with one
second on the clock so calmly so many
times exactly very very calmly exactly
pushing the clock right I would be just
banging seconds
okay the last Cheapo don't take with the
queen
that's what we call a 50 50 shot right
it takes it there's a
the last gasp well our congratulations
to Anna zatomski defeating uh Alexandra
and the tournament leader and Bella as
well
wow wow I think fine sugar used to the
time zone
I think we can't use that as an excuse
that's for sure but uh very nice I just
want to say that for Bella
um you know quite a contrast to how she
started the tournament she started the
tournament jet lag should make this
terrible blunder loses a piece uh
follows It Up by missing a moment uh so
oh and two and suddenly two and two ah
let's take a look at the standings in
fact after four rounds in the history
books congratulations to anas atomski
she's in a clear lead with three points
exactly typher second place the three
players Alexandra Costa new Nana tecnise
and Irina Crush but look at the chasing
pack at 58 as well harika Elizabeth
Bella in gunai with 50 percent
and our defending
you're kidding me
the shocking she was ready to come back
today with the win and she was very
close but terrible blunder and now she's
in the Ninth Place yeah the time travel
again making a fool of all of us as we
get ready uh
for round five coming up tomorrow
we have mama dada playing conero
tournament leaders a turn skip playing
harita drona Valley exactly Abdul Malik
playing Costa nuke
Irina Crush against Elizabeth pets
important for our tournament standings
yes and then all Georgian matchup
technique against
and it's sort of like Bella's getting
there getting into shape Nana's kind of
feeling really really good I mean
yeah yeah and tomorrow is the last round
before the rest day right so we are
going to see I'm expecting a very very
long fight yes me too so tomorrow is
round five and Thursday they'll have a
rest day then we'll be back for four
more rounds and possibly playoffs on
June 13th exactly and I know a lot of
the players are anxious to go and visit
the art museum as well as the World
Chess Hall of Fame that the the
curator's tour of what is on offer TS
Eliot uh the famous poet from St Louis
the exhibition on T.S Eliot is going on
so if you're anywhere near the
um Central West End here in St Louis do
make an effort to go there I visited the
the show it was really really nice
amazingly enough with just like a few
blocks away from where T.S Eliot grew up
really yeah and his parents home
unfortunately no longer existing but it
was just a few blocks away from here
there's a brass do you know where the
Pie pizza place is yeah there's a brass
statue there T.S Eliot good to know
right on the corner right and uh oh why
do we got we've got I do not want to
look at this
well look I mean it's only four rounds
we really had a bad day today all our
picks lost today I know I'm ashamed of
you guys look at what you did all your
picks
very very nice uh Anna Anna's feeling
the love Anna is feeling good clear
first undefeated very very impressive
very impressive sometimes it helps to be
an underdog in the tournament yes no one
expects that you're going to do so well
then you can just
relax play your chest and surprise them
right I'm not going to say it was a
perfect game it wasn't but it was a very
good game from Anna and it it's almost
one of those
um I want to say model games if you know
you're trying to sell your your
chessable course on the French defense
you'd kind of say like take a look at
this game with honestly a good Bishop a
good night versus bad I was surprised
during the interview she said that she
didn't even prepare this she was
expecting some different line exactly so
she came up with all these moves at the
board right and she didn't know when
Almira pointed out that her husband had
already played a game right so she was
not prepared for this and it just shows
that she's naturally good french defense
player exactly those pieces those black
pieces on uh A4 and C4 Outpost very very
very nice because again we're just
getting ready for our interview
um
just mentioned that when Bella start a
tournament so badly I was thinking how
do you recover from that first night
blender on move nine or something right
then second missing that stalemate
and look at her yeah that's why she is a
Grandmaster and such a strong
experienced player exactly she forgot
about those two games and won two in a
row against very strong players exactly
uh for those of you joining us late we
have to uh unfortunately for our Indian
fans refresh uh a painful moment I want
to say exactly here in uh humpy's game
she is winning this game and it's it's
not that difficult aligned to follow
Rook to E7 attacking the queen this is
the most natural move I think you can
play it was on the board which
interpreted yeah those Queen to six and
she played rookie six once right and
this is the the moment uh rookie a check
come here
stop right here because uh again this is
for those of you who are joining us late
King G7 it's white to play and win
and this is one way to do it yeah and
this is where we think that uh humpy has
missed the opportunity and the way to
point out she was in Big Time trouble
she had 40 seconds on the clock so very
easy to miss this idea exactly and the
winning move would have been Queen H1
that's really sneaky as uh you imagine
the queen is going to come in and
deliver a Checkmate on H7 and uh F7 so
Queen H1 and another idea if black were
to take on E8
if black picks up the Rook yep and queen
goes to f8 yes white needs to play Queen
D7 exactly and there's no immediate
Checkmate because black can play Queen
G7 okay but here white just starts to
pick up all the pawns with the checks
yes Queen takes these and he has no
choice you have to go to h8
check
there's no choice
and let's just pause our Demolition and
jump to Almera with our winner
uh well congratulations I suspect that
you liked it in our studio that's why
you won the game and that you came back
tell us a little bit about this position
uh you played a four did you analyze
this move before
actually no I did not analyze but I
liked it with idea A5 and somewhere
maybe taken this takes C5 and then
before or something like that so
before Castle I played A4 because I
wanted to she will take him on G3 to
open this H file
it was actually a waiting move at the
beginning yes okay that's good some
ideas so after Queen is seven we
absolutely loved A5 then maybe in the C4
then Bishop C2 Queen A5 and Bishop H4
yeah
so did you know already that you're
going to play G4 and Bishop F6 here I
had some ideas and after Queen d8 I
liked G4 more
and here I was thinking G6
and probably H5 and I think I have some
counter play
a person like the computer I don't know
why but G5 he thinks he's um maybe 35
and then H5 yeah
G5 yes and then H5 yeah probably four
engine it's not bad for black but for
humans it's not easy to play I think
and
so let's have a look at this
continuation
um tell us a little bit about your
thought process here of course the
computer has no feelings he evaluates
that this position is completely winning
but when you're attacking you're looking
for the best continuation here yes
especially during time travel it's not
easy to find the best continuation so
um I had some ideas yeah yeah that's a
very nice moves yeah
how to calculate everything and it's not
easy you know okay so let's get back
because we don't have too much time so
the position where I think that uh maybe
did you see this yes if I they yes this
idea before night view 3 I was thinking
also 55
so D4 and as you see you know the
position is very complicated so I think
both of you played well I don't know
probably we made some mistakes during
time travel but
I wanted to show you closer towards the
end that actually after age 5 G5
E6 is the terrible blunder because I
think the computer uh thinks that he
well black is winning
and but we understood that your idea was
just the uh to play did you want to play
maybe first um
I wanted but a queen takes E5 I could
not find
more text king king
h8 English well you're not winning but I
think there was some kind of a draw
which I found I don't know miraculously
it goes like this then rookie seven you
protect you protect and you use your
geometry and then the computer says that
this is a draw
nice but after E6 it's
better for black yeah yes I think so
let's get and here even I didn't see
your ideas yes she missed Queen defined
before
so that was already game over here and
the rest is the matter of the technique
you played almost the same end game yeah
so what did you think well well you were
playing trying to convert your advantage
here
so uh did you know how to win
[Laughter]
so that the technique was perfect well
congratulations once again I was
wondering if Yasser has a question
because he always has a question in
store no on the contrary we're not
worthy we thought your attack was great
we loved the intuitive play A5 Bishop F6
and it it really was a great attacking
game our congratulations keep it up and
thank you for teaching us how to play
Rook and games yeah thank you for the
lesson on The Rook endings and we are
looking forward to seeing you tomorrow
thank you Bella
thank you
wow what a round I mean talk about
shaking up the tournament uh cross table
once again as the standings I mean just
flipped uh
Anna zatonski came in clear third well
guess what she's living with clear
Forest it's nice to be uh in Seoul uh
leadership right and I said so a little
with three points and then second place
is shared by three players Costa nuke
that needs a crash and we'll see if they
can change things again tomorrow exactly
they will try uh four players at 50
Eureka Elizabeth
and it's been
quite a topsy-turvy tournament at least
the first half tomorrow will be round
five and we'll get the free date
thereafter uh but boy final words uh
Almera it's
it's it's it's been fun well it's been
fun and I'm
um so admirative of the spirit that
players have during this tournament they
fight till the very end we have a lot of
competitive games and well I don't even
know what to expect tomorrow after this
game right you know we were analyzing it
was incredibly complex and we didn't
know what the result is going to be but
that's what I wanted to say it doesn't
have to be perfect you know Edge we just
want to see the struggle and that's it
absolutely well the struggle in practice
as David bronstein might say thank you
so much for sharing your day with us
it's been a lot of fun tell your friends
where you're hanging out come and see us
tomorrow at the same time same channel
for uh the fifth uh round of the Karen
Scott thank you and see you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited